je voudrais d'abord je vais donner la
parole à Madame ménach dans un court
instant parce qu'elle a une une mise au
point à faire et qu'elle est tout à fait
légitime de faire je voudrais
simplement avec sobriété mais gravité
quand
même rappeler que nous avons appris au
début de la semaine que notre pays avait
perdu 40 dessiens
dans les opérations
entre guillemets du 7
octobre alors ce sont 40 40 morts
français qui s'inscrivent dans un grand
nombre
de de de perte internationale mais ce
sont les nôtres je crois qu'il faut être
sensible au fait que c'est une des une
des des pertes les plus lourdes que le
terrorisme et fait subir à à notre pays
au cours des dernières années et je
pense que dans un moment où les otages
paraissent un peu les grands oubliés de
de l'actualité on parle de tout on parle
on fait de la géopolitique mais on
oublie les otages on oublie les morts je
pense qu'il faut se le rappeler et je
dis ça parce que comme vous le savez la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
le président du Sénat ont décidé
euh de nous appeler d'appeler les
parlementaires mais les Français aussi à
une marche contre
l'antisémitisme qui aura lieu dimanche
alors je participerai personnellement en
tant que parlementaire à cette marche
avec l'écharpe tricolore de la
République mais je voudrais vous dire
que sauf si vous y voyez un inconvénient
j'aimerais pouvoir quand je
m'exprimerai sur si je suis amené à
m'exprimer
dans l'opinion dans les sur les médias
dire que cette Présence JE la je
l'assume au nom de la la commission tout
entière je pense que c'est une grande
cause qui doit nous réunir ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'analyse que nous faisons les
uns et les autres de ce qui s'est passé
de ce qui se passera au Moyen-Orient
mais cette face au regain
d'antisémitisme que nous observons
aujourd'hui face à la grande détresse de
la population juive française en
particulier je pense que il est bon que
nous soyons unanime à manifester notre
volonté de lutter contre l'antisémitisme
alors sauf si l'un d'entre vous pour des
raisons que je comprendrai d'ailleurs
estimer que je n'ai pas à m'exprimer en
votre nom à tous j'avais l'intention de
le faire et je voulais vous en informer
voilà ce que je voulais dire à titre
liminire car je dois dire que j'ai
ressenti je relier première phrase de
mon propos j'ai ressenti avec beaucoup
beaucoup de de
de des frroids et et de tristesse
l'annonce de cette statistique
épouvantable des 40 morts français voilà
alors maintenant nous allons dans un
instant assister écouter deux nos deux
rapporteurs sur ce dossier essentiel qui
est le dossier africain mais en
attendant madame la députée de la Somme
madame ménach estime que elle a
été mise en cause en tout cas qu'on lui
a attribué hier
une une prise de position publique qui
n'est pas la sienne et vous souhaitez
madame la députée faire une mise au
point vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président en
effet hier j'ai été mise en cause par la
ministre bne qui m'a prêté des propos
que je n'ai absolument jamais tenu donc
je souhaitais remettre ces propos
mensongers et éclaircir la situation en
réalité je le rappelle les la position
du groupe rassemblement national est
contre l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne tout simplement c'était sur
la situation des Balcans et je trouve
inadmissible que en mon absence madame
la ministre ait pu me prêter des propos
que je n'ai absolument jamais tenu voilà
je vous remercie je je vous remercie je
je tiens simplement à préciser une chose
c'est que je ne pense pas que dans
l'esprit de Madame de Madame boun cétait
trop chose que l'expression d'un
désaccord politique entre vous il n'est
pas puisque c'était je crois la question
de l'adhésion de la Serbie qu'elle dont
elle vous prêtait l'idée que vous la
souteniez l'adhésion de la Serbie à
l'Union européenne je je pense que
c'était une opinion comme les autres
elle a tout à fait eu tort puisque
céroné de de le faire mais je ne pense
pas qu'il faille y voir une
manifestation d'hostilité particulière
en tout cas ce que je tiens à vous dire
transmettraz très précisément à
l'intéressé votre observation et
j'espère qu'elle en tirera les
conséquences qui s'imposent car
effectivement il y a aucune raison de
vous prêter des propos ou des opinions
que vous n'avez pas manifesté
publiquement voilà euh maintenant mes
mes chers mais oui monsieur monsieur
Herbillon je vous en prie merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président oui j'ai demandé
la parole je je voulais juste m'exprimer
au nom des des républicains par rapport
à votre déclaration liminaire pour vous
dire que nous faisons évidemment nôtre
vos propos de manière extrêmement claire
en revanche je ne vous cache pas notre
embarras en ce qui concerne la prise de
parole d'un certain nombre de nos
collègues euh je ne veux pas du tout
rentrer dans la polémique je vous donne
juste des éléments factuels de nos
collègues qui sont pas c'est pas la plus
mauvaise façon d'entrer dans la pot qui
sont élus députés qui sont élus députés
et qui n'ont pas reconnu le caractère
absolument odieux inadmissible
barbare de l'attaque du 7 octobre et qui
euh tourne en utilisant des mots et des
périphrases autour de la réalité
factuelle telle qu'elle a été constatée
en particulier par certaines no
collègues qui se sont rendus sur place
comme ma collègue Michel Tabarot ici
présente et et voyez-vous y compris ici
monsieur le Président vous vous en
souvenez on a dû euh subir des propos de
la part de la présidente du groupe LFI
madame Panau que je considère comme tout
à fait inadmissible et qui ont entraîné
d'ailleurs une réaction de ma part qui a
été saluée par l'ensemble des collègues
de cette commission donc voilà je pense
que il serait nécessaire que un certain
nombre de collègues euh qui siègent
aussi dans cette commission euh et des
positions extrêmement claires même si
selon la formule habituelle on ne sort
de son de l'ambiguïé qu'à son détriment
voilà ce que je tenais à dire au nom au
nom des républicains parce que il y a
des moments il y a des moments dans
l'histoire ou qui mettent en cause la la
conscience humaine et qui nécessit des
prises de position extrêmement clair et
explicite parce qu'elles ne peuvent pas
il y a des situations qui ne peuvent pas
laisser prêter une quelconque ambiguïé
ou une quelconque incertitude parce que
il y a un certain nombre d'entre nous et
nous sommes nombreux qui avons et j'en
termine qui avons fondé notre engagement
public sur le refus de la Choa le refus
de l'antisémitisme qui est une chose
absolument inadmissible et condamnable
et c'est parce que c'est à ce niveau-là
de notre engagement qu'il est nécessaire
qu'un certain nombre de collègues
précisent leur
position merci je je crois que euh je
comprends très bien votre votre émotion
et il est légitime qu'il y ait des
discussions en notre chez nous sans
savoir quels sont les degrés de
responsabilité des uns et des autres
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit le
moment et et de de le faire aujourd'hui
je je faisais simplement je relayais
simplement l'appel des chefs de nos deux
assemblées pour sur une manifestation
qui était une manifestation de soutien
sur des valeurs fondamentales donc je
crois qu'il n'y a pas lieu d' avoir un
débat mais comme il y a eu une mise en
cause je vais simplement et ce sera la
seule prise de la seule prise de parole
que j'accepterai par que sinon euh
madame Tabarot et Monsieur fou seraient
fondés à me dire à me demander quand
est-ce qu'on va parler de leur rapport
je vais simplement laisser monsieur
Lecoq qui m'a demandé la parole réagir
très brièvement si vous le voulez bien
je sais que vous savez être très
percutant en étant bref monsieur euh le
vice-président merci monsieur le
Président euh d'abord sur sur la forme
je je trouve toujours difficile que des
collègues soient mis en cause alors
qu'il soit pas là pour se défendre
quelque part donc c'est le le
vice-président il est pour rien du fait
qu'il soit pas là mais c'est mais c'est
toujours mais c'est c'est toujours
compliqué quand même de de mettre en de
mettre en cause des collègues de cette
nature moi j'ai j'avais pas prévu réagir
au propos du président même si l'idée de
parler au nom de toute la commission
pouvait questionner
euh mais je pense que toute la
commission sur les questions de
l'antisémitisme est unanime je je le
pense sincèrement toute la commission
même ceux qui sont pas là euh et euh et
c'est justement parce que j'ai en tête
encore l'ensemble des termes du discours
du président bourlange à l'Assemblée
quand il y a eu le débat sur les sur sur
ces questions-là l'ensemble des termes
que je fais confiance au président
warlange parce que quand il parlera au
nom de la commission parce que je sais
qu'il ne fera pas le mélange entre le
nécessaire combat euh contre
l'antisémitisme et la nécessaire
critique de ce qui se passe et euh et il
a su le faire intelligemment avec Briot
et en pesant tous ses mots à l'occasion
de son son discours et et je pense que
il peut être à ce titre euh notre
porte-parole sur sur les questions de
l'antisémitisme et sur les questions
plus larges de ce qui se passe au
Moyen-Orient je voulais le partager avec
vous merci de votre confiance je tiens à
dire que ça ne sera pas quand je je dis
que je m'exprimerai si je suis
interrogé au au nom de la commission ce
ne sera pas sur une analyse politique de
comme je l'ai fait dans mon discours de
deun analyse politique de de la
situation Moyen-Orient mais bien sur la
la stricte défense du corpus de valeur
qui nous qui nous qui nous réunit tous
et de toute manière je tiens à dire que
effectivement vous le savez ce débat
n'est pas ce débat politique n'est pas
clos il sera au cœur de toutes nos
réflexions dans les semaines et dans les
mois qui viennent donc nous aurons
absolument l'occasion les uns et les
autres de débattre au fond des choses
voilà maintenant nous allons si vous
voulez bien aborder le le le le objet
principal de notre réunion qui est
l'examen du rapport d'information sur
les relations entre la France et
l'Afrique qui rapport présenté par
Madame Tabarot et par Monsieur fou
rapport qui a qui avait été programmé il
y a un an qui a subi
des des rebondissements des aléas des
des discussions que je qualifie avec mon
optimisme fondamental de dialectique
entre les rapportes ur et et et qui la
dialectique d'ailleurs étant s'étant
manifesté par une une pression assez
forte exercée sur l'administration ce
qui est tout à fait normal mais je crois
qu'il faut rendre hommage à Madame anise
Polycarpe qui a été effectivement au
cœur de la dialectique mais madame
Polycarpe qui est très cultivée
politiquement c'est que depuis Hegel
c'est la dialectique finit par produire
la synthèse même si c'est laborieux donc
alors le le ce rapport est est
absolument essentiel euh c'est un
rapport sur la la France et l'Afrique or
sur les deux choses je vais pas faire un
long un long développement rassurez-vous
mais quelle est quelle est la situation
de l'Afrique aujourd'hui euh ce que nous
nous voyons c'est que nous sommes que
l'Afrique exerce dans les affaires
internationales un rôle croissant ne
serais-ce que économiquement elle elle
exerce un rôle croissant elle est
devenue un acteur essentiel de la de la
communauté internationale et que donc
nous devons jeter un œil nouveau et un
œil attentif sur ce qui lui arrive
d'autre part nous voyons bien que
l'Afrique est au cœur de tous les grands
débats critiques qui sont ceux de notre
temps que ce soit celui du réchauffement
climatique que ce soit celui des
mouvements migratoires que ce soit celui
de la brutalisation du monde et des des
violences euh indescriptibles
qui se déroulent dans notre monde et qui
se sont notamment déroulé en Afrique que
ce soit à travers le Rwanda ou à travers
ce qui se passe je donne ça à titre
d'exemple hélas à l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo et et et sans
parler du Soudan de l'Éthiopie donc nous
avons vraiment un un sujet qui est
absolument essentiel
et nous sommes au cœur de euh donc des
problèmes de notre temps et puis de
notre
côté la France est également dans une
situation de modification fondamentale
nous avons une grande tradition
africaine mais c'est peut-être notre
problème d'être trop proche de l'Afrique
nous sommes trop proches historiquement
parce que nous avons joué un rôle
essentiel un rôle colonial qui qu'on
peut apprécier diversement selon les
opinions qu'on en a mais et qui crée une
situation très particulière et une
difficulté de vivre assez indiscutable
dans nos relations avec l'Afrique une
proximité géographique ce qui se passe
en Afrique est évidemment directement à
nos portes ce qui passe en Asie c'est en
Asie centrale c'est déjà très proche
mais l'Afrique c'est directement je ne
dirais pas
chezialiste mais extrêmement proche de
nous et donc nous ne pouvons nous
Français et nous européens nous ne
pouvons absolument pas nous
désintéresser de cette affaire ensuite
nous voyons bien que notre rapport à
l'Afrique c'est profondément modifié
j'ai évoqué le colonialisme nous
essayons de passer d'une phase
historique très longue de domination à
une phase historique très difficile à
faire émerger de bienveillance et de
cooppération et ça nous sommes vous
connaissez la loi de toville la loi que
tokville exprime dans l'Ancien Régime et
la Révolution quand il explique c'est
que quand les situations s'améliorent
qu'elles deviennent les plus
intolérables ce n'est pas quand les
choses vont de mal en pis dit-il que
qu'elles sont les plus dangereuses c'est
au contraire quand elles s'améliore car
le spectacle des abus qui demeure euh
est rendu d'autant plus insupportable
par la considération des abus qui ont
disparu et je pense que nous vivons ce
type de transition de façon euh
extrêmement extrêmement euh particulier
et en plus la France n'est plus on peut
estimer que c'est regrettable on peut
estimer que c'est inévitable mais n'est
plus la puissance la grande puissance
qu'elle avait coutume d'être au 19e et
dans et au 20e siècle en tout cas dans
la première moitié jusqu'en 1940 et même
grâce un peu à la magie du général de
Gaulle dans les années ultérie nous
sommes une puissance plus moyenne plus
relative nous agissons avec d'autres que
nous avec les Européens ça n'est pas
toujours facile mais nous nous avons
donc pour toutes ces raisons un effort
que en optique on qualifierait
d'accommodement de notre regard sur une
situation africaine très différente pour
toutes ces raisons il est évidemment
essentiel que cette commission se penche
de de façon précise sur ce problème et
là nous avons eu nos deux rapporteurs
madame Tabarot et Monsieur fous qui ont
travaillé depuis de longs mois sur cette
question et nous sommes évidemment très
attentifs à les entendre à les écouter
et nous j'ai la conviction que ce ce
rapport quelle que soit l'appréciation
que nous porterons les uns et les autres
sur les les conclusions que ce rapport
sera le point de départ d'une réflexion
en continue sur nos relations avec
l'Afrique parce que c'est pas quelque
chose de ponctuel que nous allons régler
aujourd'hui c'est un mouvement de
réflexion collective qui continuera
d'animer cette cette commission car
c'est vraiment au cœur de notre vocation
que de tenter d'éclairer des voix
nouvelles dans la relation entre la
France et l'Afrique donc voilà je me
permettais de situer les enjeux de ce
rapport c'est plutôt vous reconnaîtrez
que j'ai plutôt
fait un bel écrin et que maintenant vous
allez nous servir un beau
bijou un joyau oui alors je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas comment vous vous vous
vous
répartissez vous avez moi je veux bien
arbitrer mais mais je je pense que c'est
c'est pas exclu que les rapporteurs se
mettent de temps en temps d'accord
écoutez comme Monsieur fux c'est très
élégant il laisse la parole à sa à sa
collègue pour commencer et merci
monsieur le président
d'avoir ouvert cette cette séance petite
précision entre le colonialisme et la
période actuelle il y a eu la France
Afrique et je pense qu'il est important
de le garder en tête dans nos dans nos
réflexions donc mes chers collègues je
suis heureuse de vous présenter ce
rapport avec Bruno fou ce rapport
d'information sur les relations entre la
France et l'Afrique on pourrait dire la
France et Les Afriques c'est quelque
chose qu'il faudra garder en tête au
terme comme l'a rappelé le président de
plusieurs mois d'audition de travail de
déplacement nous en avons fait un et et
il était intéressant je remercie très
sincèrement le président l'a fait je
pense que Bruno le fera également Anaïs
Polycarpe qui a été un élément
exceptionnel à no à nos côtés à la fois
au niveau de sa qualité et de sa volonté
de de trouver des solutions à un certain
nombre de problèmes qui se présentaient
à nous je le rappelle c'est une chance
pour notre commission monsieur le
Président d'avoir des administrateurs de
cette qualitéis profondément convaincu
absolument l'ampleur du sujet fait que
la mission était complexe de plus
jusqu'à la dernière minute nous avons dû
suivre les évolutions au Mali au Niger
et dans d'autres pays mais c'était
important de réaliser cette étude parce
que l'Afrique est un continent en pleine
mutation qu'il dispose de grandes
richesses dans tous les sens du terme et
qu'il a un potentiel de croissance très
important il est devenu le terrain
d'affrontement direct ou indirect entre
les grandes puissances dans cette lutte
il apparaît évid éidemment que la France
doit se doter d'une nouvelle stratégie
africaine c'est dans cette optique que
nous avons réalisé nos travaux je ne
vais pas revenir sur tout le contenu du
rapport mais simplement évoquer en
quelques points en quelques mots les
points qui sont important pour pour moi
le premier sujet c'est la raison de la
perte d'influence de la France en
Afrique les causes sont bien entendu
nombreuses il y a d'abord notre propre
responsabilité contrairement à nos
concurrents nous nous avons été
incapable d'antici d'anticiper les
mutations du continent nous nous sommes
aussi enfermés dans le rôle de gendarme
de l'Afrique de l'Ouest pendant ce temps
nos concurrents stratégiques ont fait
des affaires et gagné des parts de
marché nous avons aussi démoli tout ce
qui fonctionnait bien dans notre
relation nous avons diminué par 10 le
nombre de nos coopérants il y a moins
d'écoles françaises l'aide publique au
développement ne touche plus assez
directement les populations nos deux
derniers présidents ont annoncé la fin
de la politique africaine de la France
et ce message a été très mal perçu par
nos partenaires je pense que c'était une
erreur ils ont d'ailleurs été rattrapés
par les crises qui se succèdent en
Afrique francophone avec le risque vu
par de nombreux experts que le prochain
califat islamiste n'émerge au milieu du
Sahel notre perte d'influence est aussi
liée à la compétition stratégique
pendant longtemps l'Afrique a été
dédaignée par les grandes puissances à
part pour des visés politiques pendant
la guerre froide ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui le continent attire de
nouveaux compétiteurs stratégiques qui
ont des méthodes parfois très agressives
sur le plan économique avec l'attitude
prédatrice de la Chine sur le plan
culturel et religieux avec la Turquie et
sur le plan sécuritaire avec la Russie
qui utilise les méthodes les plus
déplorables pour arriver à ses fins en
manipulant les populations
elle se sert aussi des mercenaires du
groupe Wagner entité qui est bien plus
structurée qu'on ne le pense comme nous
l'ont rappelé les journalistes Alexandra
jousseé Xenia
bolchakova ce sont des femmes très
courageuses que nous avons eu la chance
d'entendre enfin notre perte d'influence
est aussi liée aux tension actuelle dans
les pays africains nous sommes devenus
les bouqu émissaires des gentes qui
légitiment leur pouvoir sur la haine de
la France ils vont jusqu'à dire que nous
soutiendrions les les djihadistes je
trouve cela honteux en pensant à nos
militaires morts au Sahel justement pour
lutter contre les
terroristes il y a aussi d'autres sujets
de tension récurrent dont je vais parler
rapidement d'abord le Fran CFA qui
nourrit absolument tous les fantasmes au
moins sur ce point la France est claire
les pays africains ont totalement la
main c'est à eux d'achever sa réforme et
d'en sortir s'ils le veulent autre sujet
de tension je pense que mon collègue
Bruno en parlera la question des visas
il ne faut pas la confondre avec
l'immigration irrégulière et je rappelle
mon attachement total à la maîtrise des
flux mais nous en parlerons dans
quelques jours des pays performants en
matière d'immigration ont une politique
de visa assumée et efficace c'est
aujourd'hui ce qui manque à la France
comme le dit le rapport Hermelin il faut
avoir une politique enfin lisible
notalement notamment pour ceux dont les
visas sont renouvelés depuis des années
et qui du jour au lendemain se heurent à
un mur nous avons des exemples
d'entrepreneurs ou d'étudiants qui ont
fait toute leur scolarité dans notre
réseau et qui veulent venir en France
finir leurs études il pourraient être
nos meilleurs ambassadeurs et nous leur
fermons la porte aujourd'hui disons-le
clairement notre pays perd des
opportunités faute d'une doctrine d'une
doctrine claire j'en appelle d'ailleurs
à limiter l'externalisation du
traitement des visas et consacré plus de
moyens dans nos représentations parce
qu'il faut reprendre la main mes chers
collègues pour ne pas uniquement noircir
le tableau je dois aussi dire que la
perte d'influence n'est pas généralisée
la France parvient à développer ses
relations avec des pays dans sa sphère
d'influence mais surtout en dehors je
soutiens d'ailleurs sans réserve
l'ouverture vers l'Afrique anglophone ou
l'usophone qui nous permet de construire
de nouveaux partenariats au-delà de nos
liens historiques j'en viens maintenant
à ma vision de ce que pourrait être la
nouvelle stratégie africaine de la
France notre pays doit prendre
conscience que le monde a profondément
changé notre diplomatie d'influence ne
peut plus s'appuyer sur des conceptions
anciennes nous devons aussi être capable
de dire clairement ce que nous faisons
la France doit assumer sa stratégie
d'influence pour ça il faudra de
profonds changements à tous les niveaux
sur le plan stratégique je soutiens une
ouverture réelle du champ de la
politique étrangère nous l'avons encore
vu récemment avec le déplacement du chef
de l' éat au Proche-Orient nous
parlementaires nous avons dû attendre
qu'il soit facee caméra sur le terrain
pour savoir ce qu'il allait dire c'était
aussi visiblement le cas de la ministre
des Affaires étrangères et de tout le
gouvernement qui ont été pris par
surprise résultat personne n'a soutenu
son son message parce que personne n'y
était préparé pas même nos alliés le
manque de concertation est un problème
majeur le domaine réservé doit s'ouvrir
il doit redevenir
un véritable domaine partagé pour cela
je propose l'instauration d'un Conseil
des Affaires étrangères à l'Élysée il
pourrait associer tous les ministres
concernés Affaires étrangères économie
partenariat armée voir l'intérieur si
nécessaire nous souhaitons aussi la
nomination d'un ministre des
partenariats de plein exercice nous
voulons également un vrai rôle du
Parlement avec au moins deux débats par
an sur la politique africaine je je le
répète il faut désormais aérer notre
politique étrangère elle ne peut plus
dépendre que d'un seul homme le deuxième
niveau d'action c'est celui de l'aide
publique au développement j'en ai parlé
il y a peu de temps ici même et ça avait
suscité des réactions de la part de nos
collègues qui sont membres du conseil
d'administration de la FD mais je
maintiens qu'il faut redonner un vrai
pilotage politique à
l'AFD je rejoins en cela la Cour des
comptes en disant cela je n'attaque pas
lafd mais je pointe surtout la
responsabilité du politique qui s'est
désinvesti à tort j'assume de vouloir
politiser l'aide au développement en
cohérence avec notre diplomatie
d'influence et de réclamer plus de
moyens à disposition de nos ambassades
pour soutenir des projets locaux qui
touchent les populations c'est comme
cela que nous auront un impact direct
positif nos concurrents savent très bien
le faire et ils en tirent énorme
avantage sur
nous pour mettre tout cela en œuvre nous
soutenons une réforme de l'AFD dont nous
proposons d'ailleurs de changer le nom
en France
partenariat le gouvernement lui-même
remplace le terme développement par la
notion d'investissement solidaire et
durable cela permettrait aussi de
valoriser le nom France bien plus
fortement que le simple sigle
AFD notre commission pourrait j'en suis
certaine travailler très utilement
préparer une telle réforme j'en viens
maintenant au rôle de nos ambassades
nous avons un formidable réseau qui
peut-être une chance à condition de lui
donner des moyens il faut une véritable
filière Afrique au k d'oré et valoriser
les carrières nous devons aussi recréer
un institut des hautes études de
l'Afrique nous pourrions également nous
inspirer des États-Unis qui préparent
pendant des mois leurs nouveaux
diplomates avant de les envoyer dans un
pays et je redis ici mon opposition à la
réforme du corps diplomatique qui
affaiblit nos représentants nos
représentations à
l'étranger ce n'est vraiment pas le
moment de renoncer à ce qui fait notre
force des créations de postes sont
annoncées je souhaite qu'elle bénéficie
prioritairement à notre représentation
en
Afrique quelques mots aussi concernant
notre présence
militaire bien sûr la situation est
difficile après le Mali et le Burkina
Faso soldat quitte désormais le Niger
mais nous avons vu des pays où la
présence française est voulue comme en
Côte d'Ivoire la règle doit être simple
soyons là où il y a un désir de France
pour ça il faut renforcer nos
partenariats et il faut faire évoluer
notre offre stratégique pour répondre
aux besoins des pays africains nos
compétiteurs l'ont bien compris ils ont
adapter leurs
proposition c'est vrai aussi pour le
matériel l'offre de notre BITD ne
correspond pas assez aux attentes de nos
partenaires le résultat c'est qu'ils
finissent par acheter des drones et des
équipements bon marché à d'autres pays
comme la
Turquie la France doit repenser son
offre pour satisfaire nos alliés à
défaut de quoi nous continuerons à
perdre du terrain ce travail est en
cours et je ne doute pas que le
ministère des armées nous en tiendra
informé enfin le dernier point c'est
notre capacité à communiquer sur ce que
nous faisons sincèrement ce qui nous a
été dit à ce sujet est très contrariant
les médias publics français qui sont vu
comme la voix de la France en Afrique
rela régulièrement des critiques et
parfois des messages haineux contre la
France je ne dicte évidemment pas leur
ligne éditorial mais il faut une
cohérence les médias ne peuvent pas
servir de caisse de résonance aux
ennemis de notre pays sans prendre aussi
le soin de de montrer des points de
vuees différents je l'ai vu pour le
Niger évidemment les manifestants
étaient contre nous mais ne pas trouver
un contradicteur pour modérer le message
c'est un problème des acteurs africains
eux-mêmes nous ont dit ne pas comprendre
pourquoi nos médias ne valorisaient pas
plus l'action de la France nos médias
publics doivent s'y attacher un peu plus
parce qu'ils sont l'un des socles de
notre diplomatie d'influence ils doivent
aussi participer plus fortement à lutter
contre la désinformation dont nous
sommes victimes ici encore le
gouvernement a annoncé des initiatives
qui sont encore sous-doté il faut
veiller à les renforcer parce que c'est
essentiel pour l'image de la France nous
soutenons enfin une communication plus
directe qui pourrait être porté aussi
par des relais d'influence locaux
identifiés par la France ainsi mes chers
collègues ces propositions sont
ambitieuses mais elles visent à
renforcer notre diplomatie d'influence
dans une logique de coopération et de
partenariat renforcé efficace j'espère
que nous aurons la possibilité de
poursuivre l'ensemble de cette réflexion
très importante et d'assurer dans le
cadre de notre commission le suivi de
ces préconisations qui dessinent les
contour de ce qui pourrait être la
stratégie africaine de la France je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
madame la
rapporteur monsieur fou va s'exprimer
vous avez parlé 12 minutes ce qui est
tout à fait tout à fait raisonnable pour
le président et je pense que Monsieur
fou tiendra dans un un espace-temp
comparable je voulais simplement faire
une seule précision à ce que vous avez
dit évidemment je me garderais bien de
de discuter les propositions très très
nombreuses très riches que vous avez
formulé mais je voudrais rappeler aux
collègues le rapport de mon
prédécesseur la chère Marielle de sarnaz
qui avait fait sur la question des visas
que vous avez évoqué un rapport très
intéressant dans lequel elle avait
suggéré c'est la Commission avait porté
cette idée en son temps elle avait
suggéré l'idée d'un visa d'un d'un visa
qui serait à utilisation
euh pluriel c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un
ce qui éviterait les Accous que vous
avez que vous avez évoqué le le jeune
étudiant a un visa pour 5 ans il repart
dans son pays il revient et cetera et et
et et il peut donc se servir de de ce
visa en s'exposant en évitant des des
des des des contraintes bureaucratiques
et des absurdités bureaucratiques parce
qu'on sait bien que cette question ces
visas sont gérés d'une façon
extraordinairement arbitraire
actuellement donc je voulais simplement
vous rappeler mes chers collègues que de
ce point de vue-là la commission n'avait
n'avait pas n'était pas en terrain
incognita et que Mariel dez dans cet
excellent rapport qu'elle avait fait au
début de sa mandature avait gérer cette
idée maintenant cher Bruno c'est à vous
monsieur le corapporteur de
euh d'entraîner cette commission merci
Monsieur le le Président chers collègues
merci beaucoup Michel d'avoir été très
très complète je vais essayer de de de
donner quelques éléments comme le
rapport est extrêmement riche qui
viennent compléter ce que vient de de
dire Michel Tabarot et je voulais
commencer par effectivement des des
remerciements extrêmement chaleureux
sincères et et ressenti au quotidien
pour Anaïs Polycarpe qui a porté ce
rapport et qui permet aujourd'hui
d'arriver devant vous la couronne de
fleurs remplacera la couronne des PES
voilà ce sera décter de mon temps de
parole monsieur le Président mais mais
mais ça valait le coup ça valait le coup
n'hésitez pas à
interagir n'hésitez pas à interagir à
tout
moment alors après 6 mois de de travail
je pense qu'on est arrivé à la
conclusion que que euh on n'a jamais été
autant contesté en Afrique depuis la fin
des
indépendances mais pour reprendre les
les propos du du Président je pense
qu'on n jamais été aussi prêt de pouvoir
transformer notre action et de résoudre
une partie euh des des des
problématiques pour rétablir des
relations fécondes pour cela il faut
deux choses que ma corpportrice a a
abordé il faut d'abord changer assez
radicalement de logiciel et et pour ça
il faut avoir un plan d'action c'est pas
une ou deux mesures mais comme Michel
Tabor l'a montré c'est un plan d'action
complet sur toutes les dimensions de
notre action qui permettront de
retrouver des relations équilibrées
c'est ce que souhaitent nos partenaires
africains et respectueuse des intérêts
euh des des deux parties en réalité euh
il faut voir que sur le terrain euh euh
les les nos amis nos partenaires
africain euh aiment plutôt les Français
en tout cas de bonne relation avec eux
ils vous disent pas qu'ils n'aiment pas
les Français ils vous disent que ils
veulent une France autrement les
relations individuelles sont bonnes mais
c'est les relations politiques c'est
l'action global de de la France qui
provoque ces ces turbulences alors
comment ce faossé c'est c'est creusé
progressivement euh ce n'est pas arrivé
du jour au lendemain c'est les résultat
de tendance très lourde qu'on décrit
bien dans le rapport et que j'essaie de
reprendre pour deux ou trois d'entre
elles mais avant tout je voudrais dire
que nous avons de nombreux avantages
compétitifs c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis pas pessimiste sur la
nature de nouvelles relations que l'on
pourra proposer avec l'Afrique alors
c'est principalement l'Afrique
francophone parce que comme Michel
Tabarot l'a dit en Afrique anglophone on
est des relations tout à fait normal de
de de partenariat tout à fait normal
parce que nous aussi nous avons des
comportements qui sont différents en
Afrique anglophone ou luusophone qu'en
Afrique francophone d'abord on est très
précurseur et on est des des des gros
point d'avantage par rapport à nos
concurrents russes chinois américains
Turcs sur les politiques de santé sur la
politique de défense de la biodiversité
sur la politique liée au climat nous
avons des des mettons des moyens très
importants sur le développement de
l'entreprenoriat de l'éducation la
formation de la parité donc on on on a
quand même des avantages et
paradoxalement on ne communique pas ou
très peu sur ce que l'on apporte à nos
partenaires africains on communique on
se laisse communiquer on en fait dans on
est dans un rôle subi on est en réaction
aux événements parce que on communique
principalement quand on parle de la
France sur les questions militaires ou
sur les questions politiques mais je le
montre là on a d'autres sujets sur
lesquels on est au quotidien en Afrique
avec nos partenaires et avec les
citoyens africains et sur ces plans-là
on apporte une contribution
importante euh à la création de valeur
et et au processus de développement des
pays africains depuis 2017 on a lancé
des politiques ambitieuses sur la
mémoire sur la restitution des des
œuvres d'art sur le franc CFA qui
aujourd'hui est à la main des pays
africains qui ne prennent pas cette
possibilité d'aller jusqu'au bout sur le
Fran CFA on a également entrepris la
restitution de d'œuvres d'art on a
marqué également une un doublement de
notre aide au au développement en terme
de de montant donc on le voit nous avons
beaucoup d'avantages avons une culture
commune nous avons un passé commun nous
avons des complicités communes et des
programmes sur lesquels nous pouvons
bâtir une nouvelle stratégie qui a été
annoncée en 2017 par le Président de la
République et qui pour les raisons qu'on
explique dans le le rapport sont encore
pour une partie importante d'entre elles
rester en jacher ou ou ou lettre morte
alors
d'abord qu'est-ce qui nous manque
qu'est-ce qui nous a manqué Michel d'Aro
l'a dit on n' pas vu l'Afrique évoluer
on n' pas vu que depuis 30 ans par
exemple sur la démographie le Niger en
1960 faisait 3 millions d'habitants
aujourd'hui c'est 25 millions en 2050 ce
sera 70 millions ce ce ce continent en
2100 normalement
pourrait voir plus de 4 milliards et
demi de d'habitants donc c'est une
croissance ABS absolument incroyable au
Sénégal l'âge médian d'un Sénégal est de
19 ans donc la moitié des Sénégalais
nont de relations avec la France que de
réseaux sociaux ou de médias sur
lesquels ils ils alimentent de la
relation avec la France ils n'ont pas
connu une relation de de proximité avec
des maîtres d'école avec une relation de
de proximité très grande avec la
France alors et puis Michel Tabarot l'a
dit la la la la compétition c'est
continent qui est devenu un un continent
prisé très important dans on le voit
dans les années à venir ce sera un
continent stratégique les Chinois ont
mis en 20 ans 150 milliards de dollars
de dons en Afrique plus les
investissements extrêmement important
que les Chinois font donc il y a une
concurrence à laquelle nous n'avons pas
vu réellement que nous devions changer
nos nos méthode de de fonctionnement et
et notre approche deuxème élément euh
aujourd'hui les Africains nous nous nous
disent mais que faites-vous en Afrique
on ne comprend pas ce que vous êtes en
train de faire en Afrique est-ce que
vous êtes là pour défendre la démocratie
la démocratie est-ce que vous êtes là
pour défendre vos intérêts est-ce que
vous êtes là pour rétablir la paix en
fait on a en fonction des situations des
actions à géométrie variable et donc euh
tout ça vient d'une tendance très très
longue en en gros doctrine aujourd'hui
n'est plus comprise que Michel Tabor il
faut redéfinir une une offre stratégique
après les indépendances le général de
Gaulle a une offre très claire que que
Poutine reprend aujourd'hui je de
l'indépendance mais j'assure la sécurité
et et de l'aide contre votre loyauté en
clair hein globalement vous votez pour
la France au Conseil de sécurité et à
l'onuance avec la France oui dans les
positions françaises donc ça c'est une
qui bien sûr contestable qui correspond
à une époque mais qui est une position
claire le discours de Labau du du
président mitteran et l'avantage c'est
qu'il bien sû beaucoup plus vertueux
c'est qui conditionne notre aide et et
le développement au développement de
démocratie mais
euh la la résultante c'est que cette
nouvelle approche et dans les faits
réalisés de façon extrêmement partielle
des pays y a des pays dans lesqu el on
le fait et des pays dans lequels cette
doctrine est mise en
contradiction François mitteran pardon
François Hollande par exemple n'avait
plus de relation avec le président obang
de Guinée équatoriale pour les raisons
de di Malaki et de gouvernance
contestable la France continue d'avoir
des relations avec le voisin le Gabon
extrêmement proche au plan politique et
au plan économique des tas de
contradictions qui font que
progressivement les
Africains doutent de notre sincérité et
chez nous chaque fois un agenda caché ou
des positions qui ne sont pas claires
avec un intérêt français qui n'est pas
exprimé et donc ça c'est un le sujet
majeur ça amène ensuite à ce qu'on a
appelé des des des des héritants pour
pouvoir développer un plan d'action et
retrouver des relations de confiance il
va falloir évoluer aujourd'hui sur un
certain nombre de sujets la question des
visas bien sûr a été rappelée elle est
absolument centrale mais il y a
également la question de du double
standard aujourd'hui vous avez des pays
dans lesquels on a une approche qui
n'est pas la même que dans le pays
voisin je viens de le dire il y a la
question également de l'attitude on nous
reproche beaucoup nous Français tous les
Français d'avoir une attitude
extrêmement paternaliste parfois
arrogante dit-on cette attitude là on ne
l'a pas dans d'autres pays ou dans
d'autres pays d'Afrique même donc il
faut arriver à faire une une vraie
révolution mentale pour avoir des
comportements d'égal à égal il y a
beaucoup d'exemples certains sont donnés
dans dans le rapport mais au quotidien
vous vous avez des des personnes qui
témoignent de de cette double attitude
en tout cas d'attitude souvent
condescendante alors il nous faudra
transformer également notre organisation
pour mieux répondre aux besoins et
rétablir des partenariats égaux
respectueux des intérêts des deux
parties Michel Tabaro certain nombre de
de grands plans sur lequel nous devons
transformer notre
action les investissements solidaires
bien sûr lafd avec un changement de nom
la création d'un d'un ministère de des
des partenariats et de de l'Afrique
c'est un un ministère important car
aujourd'hui il y a la a une atomisation
ou une centralisation ça dépend des
sujets de l'action en en Afrique et donc
on a perdu principal
la connaissance de l'Afrique on est
resté sur une connaissance d' y a
quelques années et on a perdu cette
connaissance on a moins de gens sur le
terrain beaucoup moins Michel l'a dit on
écoute beaucoup moins les chercheurs
beaucoup moins les experts on écoute
beaucoup moins les journalistes et donc
on perd cette connaissance fil de
l'Afrique donc il faut remettre des gens
et et des experts sur le terrain
l'Allemagne par exemple à quasiment la
moitié suivant les les les projets de
ces investissements qui sont dans
l'exper tise humaine nous on fait à 90 %
de l'infrastructure ou des
investissements il faut investir dans
l'humain et dans l'accompagnement des
projets ça c'est un une transformation
assez importante à à faire alors les
propositions Michel en a en a en a parlé
je pense qu'elles sont partagées pour la
la la
plupart la question qui se pose c'est
quelle approche on doit avoir en terme
de de démocratie sur cette question là
on a repris en tout cas j'ai repris la
euh la l'approche d'achil membé qui est
de dire euh sur la question de
démocratie il faut avoir une juste
distance c'est-à-dire qu'il faut être
solide sur nos euh nos nos valeurs nos
principes démocratiques la gouvernance
des pays l'égalité entre les les
citoyens la vision multilatérale du
monde les libertés publique je on ne
lâche rien en revanche on évite de faire
de l'ingérence euh dans euh les pays
parce que ces pays ont sont dotés de de
gouvernance et qu'on voit bien qu'en
faisant de l'ingérence on arrive souvent
à à des résultats inverses à ce que l'on
veut on donne également des exemples
dans le rapport là-dessus ensuite il
faudra bien sûr trouver une plateforme
stratégique on donne des des des
éléments dans dans le rapport qui
permettent à chaque fois de savoir et
d'exprimer il faut dire clairement quels
sont nos intérêts quand nous allons
quelque part on a des intérêts il faut
le dire clairement la plupart du temps
je vais terminer là-dessus quand euh on
on est mal compris ça étit vrai en
Guinée c'est vrai au Chad et cetera
c'est qu'on n'exprime pas les raisons
pour lesquelles nous intervenons comme
ça parce qu'en général ces raisons sont
variables en fonction des pays donc une
plateforme stratégique c'est la première
étape qu'il faut mettre en place pour
que notre action soit lisible elle soit
claire elle soit partagé et qu'on puisse
recréer des relations de confiance avec
nos partenaires africains
je vous remercie
infiniment monsieur le le rapporteur
maintenant nous allons donner la parole
au groupe
et je pour Renaissance c'est monsieur
ledou qui va je crois se lancer
hardiment dans le
débat merci Monsieur
président attendez voilà excusez-moi
allez-y merci monsieur le
président
d'autre non qu'est-ce qui se passe il y
a quelqu'un quelqu'un a allumé son
micro de Me pren si vous voulez merci
monsieur le Président ça marche chers
collègues je remercie les rapporteurs
pour leur travail sur un sujet très
difficile très ample qui nécessite de se
garder des appréciations à
l'emporte-pièce mais je dois cependant
exprimer des regret car nous navons
quelque peu fait mentir gel la
dialectique n'a pas produit la synthèse
que nous attendions je suis d'accord sur
le constat que vous faites he d'une
attente de la part de nombreux Africains
d'une offre stratégique de long terme
afin de maintenir des liens nourri plus
égalitaire et c'est bien des
orientations qui ont été engagées depuis
2017 impulsé par le Président de la
République qui a fait de la diplomatie
la priorité africaine de la France et
qui n'ont pas du tout été définis en vas
clos comme le rapport semble l'indiquer
au contraire elles ont été débattues
approuvées coconstruites ici même euh
avec des textes que nous avons voté pour
permettre la montée en puissance la
réorientation de l'aide publique au
développement la réforme du Fran CFA ou
encore le travail conjoint sur le
patrimoine africain qui inclut des
restitutions sans illimité alors
pourquoi dès lors multiplier les
remarque désobligeantes à l'égard du
président de la République ou de ses
collaborateurs sur la base de fait
parfois monter en épingle et c'est
légumes des choses je dois aussi
regretter des angles morts qui ne sont
pas anodins des projets concrets
considérables sont mis en place au plan
culturel et économique qui méritent
d'être présentés évaluer et non pas
balayer en quelques lignes au motif que
tout n'irait pas assez vite donc ma
première question porte sur ce qui selon
vous marche ou ne marche pas dans les
partenariats concrets que nous avons mis
en place en matière culturelle et
économique notamment ensuite je note que
l'Europe est absente de vos analyses
comme si la France n'était pas membre de
l'Union européenne or notre action en
Afrique ne peut pas méconnaître les
logiques européennes les instruments
propres de l'Union notamment en matière
de développement ou encore les attentes
des Africains pour qui le partenariat
avec la France est un point d'entrée
vers l'Europe et donc selon vous quelle
est donc aujourd'hui et quelle doit être
la dimension européenne de la politique
africaine de la France concernant les
visas que recommandez-vous concrètement
pour promouvoir les circulations des
acteurs des sociétés civiles et au-delà
des intentions quelle est la bonne
méthode pour avancer enfin je n'ai rien
trouvé dans le rapport sur les échanges
entre les territoires français et
africains c'est-à-dire la coopération
décentralisé mais aussi les échanges
entre association réseau professionnel
fondation c'est un pan majeur de la mise
en relation concrète des sociétés sur
lesquelles à la demande du Premier
ministre édard Philippe j'avais il y a
quelques temps commis un un rapport il y
a là un terro considérable que certains
postes diplomatiques ses force de
mobiliser mais qui est parfois
sous-utilisé il permet de dessiner une
autre géographie notre relation à
l'Afrique loin des idées reçues est-ce
que vous avez constaté des avancées en
la matière depuis 2017 mes chers
collègues notre perception des enjeux de
la relation entre la France et l'Afrique
ne doit pas être sur déterminé par
l'agitation des pchises du Sael et
d'influenceurs proorusses ou salafistes
un avenir comme vous l'avez constaté un
potentiel considérable sont devant nous
mais également des défis et des risques
il s'agit d'un chantier de longue
haleine et je forme le vœux pour que
nous puissions poursuivre ce travail au
sein de la commission et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le groupe renissance
s'abstiendra sur ce rapport merci à
vous bien mais écoutez c'est une sévère
estockade alors non pas là s'il te plaît
euh je vais laisser les les
les rapporteur répondre effectivement je
ne suis pas absolument sûr qu' soit l'un
et l'autre cont tenu de leurs leurs
engagements politiques respectifs tout à
fait sur la même ligne ce qui est très
très logique donc ils vont je leur donne
à à chacun 2
minutes merci euh monsieur le Président
merci pour cette intervention euh
vigoureuse au au au petit matin mais je
l'ai dit euh dès le départ c'était le
début de mon intervention il y a
énormément de choses qui sont mises en
place qui fonctionnent j'ai fait la
liste non pas exhaustive mais de
programmes qui ont été lancés mais
qu'aujourd'hui euh on ne le valorise pas
suffisamment c'est une question de
perception on est coincé par nos actions
militaires sur lesquelles on est en
réaction permanente on est coincé sur
les questions de gouvernance politique
de soutien à des régimes on fait un
encadré sur le Gabon qui est très clair
là-dessus et c'est ça la la question
c'est pas tellement ce qu'on fait c'est
ce qu'on dit que ce que l'on fait c'est
ça la la question après on peut faire du
wishful thinking et dire que tout va
bien on n serait pas dans cette
situation bien sûr qu'on peut dire que
c'est très localisé que la question de
de désamour de l'Afrique et la France
c'est lié au Sahel et à quelques pays
mais attention si on ne traite pas cette
question comme nous l'avons abordé avec
clairvoyance avec franchise sans tabou
même si c'est dans vos propre camp
politique et bien ça va se viraliser ça
va on voit bien les choses sont
contagieuses euh voilà vous allez en en
République Démocratique du du Congo les
gens vous disent on attend la France on
a besoin de la France on a envie de
parttir avec la France la France ne
vient pas la France n'est pas là euh au
au en RDC par exemple et c'est un autre
point que je que je voulais répondre euh
euh le le problème il est pas les
programmes qu'on lance le problème il
est de la mise en œuvre de ces
programmes on a du mal à les mettre en
œuvre et à les réaliser de façon massive
le président de la République est allé
en RDC a fait des annonces nombre
d'investissements qu'il a annoncé moi
j'ai constaté 4 mois après que rien
n'avait été mis en œuvre pour l'instant
rien concrètement donc on peut faire des
annonces on peut annoncer beaucoup de
choses il faut voir sur le terrain les
choses qui sont réellement réalisées et
c'est là-dedans que nous pêchons sur
l'Europe on a un paragraphe sur l'Europe
qui est qui est qui qui est très clair
et et moi je dis toujours que si on ne
renforce pas et on n'amène pas nos
partenaires européens à travailler sur
l'Afrique a montré que l'Afrique est
très importante et stratégique on ne
fera pas seul mais il y a un paragraphe
vous navez pas dû voir peut-être dans la
lecture rapide que vous avez faite vous
n'avez pas dû voir ce paragraphe sur
l'Europe on a traité CE ce sujet et pour
terminer c'est ce ce sujet de rafrique
est est tellement large qu'effectivement
on est obligé de de faire des des
impasses on n pas pu en 6 mois couvrir
tous les champs mais sur la coopération
décentralisée il y a une proposition
là-dessus on n' pas pu la la couvrir
parce que il s'agit pas de politique
publique nationale mais de la capacité
des États et ce qu'on demande c'est
qu'il y ait une coordination justement
des politiques décentralisées avec la
stratégie générale exuse- oui si la
lecture de du rapport a été rapide par
Monsieur ledou que je ne sais pas c'est
en tout cas qu' a pas eu beaucoup de
temps euh de l'approfondir parce qu'on
peut pas dire qu'on nous a laissé vous
avez reçu ce rapport en en mission il y
a près d'un an je crois et on l'a reçu
nous euh lundi après-midi au milieu de
de de d'emploi du temps extrêmement
serré et effectivement nous avons tous
été amené moi le premier à faire une
lecture un peu cursive euh il ne vous
aura pas échappé mes chers collègues que
c'était la partie défensive du président
de la République puisque monsieur
monsieur fou est membre de la majorité
et maintenant je pense qu'on va avoir la
partie critique avec Madame Tabarot vous
non écoutez on on a travaillé
intelligemment mais je pense que si si
on veut se si on veut se se faire euh
euh enfin se bercer d'illusion c'est
tout à fait possible vous pouvez être
ravi de de de tout ce qu'a fait le
président Macron et on a pris la peine
de de regarder les erreurs on a parlé de
l'erreur de Nicolas Sarkozi on a parlé
des erreurs de de François Hollande dans
ce dans ce ce rapport et on a parlé des
erreurs de de d'Emmanuel Macron si tout
allait bien monsieur ledou on n'aurait
pas cette mission d'information et
aujourd'hui on se poserait pas la
question de nos relations avec l'Afrique
et particulièrement avec l'Afrique
francophone parce que tout tout tout
irait bien et que les propositions
d'Emmanuel Macron auraient été
accueillies avec beaucoup de plaisir on
a eu deux choses c'est à la fois des
propositions et ensuite pas de mise en
œuvre donc je pense qu'il faut un petit
peu d'humilité il faut accepter ce qui
ne va pas aujourd'hui et se dire comment
on fait pour redémarrer quel que soient
nos sensibilités politiques euh de de
toute façon les majorités sont là
aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas là demain
l'intérêt c'est que le pays le notre
notre pays remett en place un un lien
étroit avec l'Afrique alors on l'a dit
ça passe par des visas on peut penser
que tout va bien mais tout ne va pas
bien et on a et je pense que vous avez
en tant que parlementaire des
témoignages permanents de gens qui ont
par exemple fait leurs études ont eu des
bourses pour faire leurs études dans des
écoles françaises et n'arrivent pas
ensuite à venir venir continuer leur
cursus scolaire en France parce qu'ils
sont refusés vous avez des chefs
d'entreprise qui sont en lien avec la
France qui vont faire un allerretour
simplement on va pas les garder 5 ans ou
20 ans sur sur le territoire national
ils veulent juste avoir la possibilité
de venir ils ne peuvent pas venir on a
des professeurs d'université qui
interviennent dans des universités
françaises qui se voient refuser des des
visas donc il y a quand même des petits
soucis qu'il faut quand même souligner
vous avez parlé de l'Europe on on a
parlé de l'Europe on a parlé de l'Europe
et on a parlé de l'Europe à la fois elle
existe mais on a aussi des compétiteurs
au sein de l'Europe et vous verrez que
les Allemands et bien ont de bien
meilleurs résultats que la France
aujourd'hui ils se sont totalement
désintéressés de la partie militaire et
des accords que nous pouvons nous avoir
avec un certain nombre de pays africains
et et donc ils se sont centrés sur sur
des accords économiques et ça marche
très bien pour eux donc on a malgré tout
des réflexions à à mener et et se dire
ce qui est important de de de faire
évoluer pour qu'on arrive enfin à à
reprendre une relation avec les pays
africains différente de ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et particulièrement dans ces
pays francophones où nous avons une
histoire où nous avons un potentiel où
on nous attend c'est-à-dire que comme
l'a rappelé Bruno fou il y a une envie
de France mais aujourd'hui il considère
que sur plusieurs sujets nous sommes pas
à la hauteur merci merci Madame merci
Madame Tabaro je crois que les les
réponses ont été
important
non les les non la violence vous savez
c'est autre chose que la mise en cause
de Monsieur le dou nous sommes c'est une
mise en cause sévère et je crois que
c'est annonce qu' vote pas ah bah oui ça
c'est n'a pas le dro pas très sympa si
on a non mais ça c'est pas le problème
chacun a le droit d'exprimer ses
mais
jeveb très intéressant vous avez répondu
l'un et l'autre avec beaucoup de
vivacité et et et et de et c'était un
échange très intéressant vou oui oui je
voulais juste rajouter un point quand on
parle d'une d'un d'un isolement au
niveau de cette politique vous le savez
très bien il y a un Monsieur Afrique à
l'Élysée vous avez l'Élysée et Monsieur
Afrique et Monsieur Afrique pendant des
années a décidé de beaucoup de choses en
se privant de l'expertise de des membres
du vous aurez l'occasion vous avez
encore un beaucoup de prise de parole et
donc vous aurez l'occasion de dire un
certain nombre de choses vous voulez
encore dire quelque chose juste sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
juste sur l'efficacité politiques
publiqu on a mis en place la restitution
d'œuvr d'art et bien aujourd'hui les
Allemands sont bien plus avancés que
nous on a été initiateurs les Allemands
font beaucoup plus que nous donc voilà
on a des difficultés à mettre en œuvre
il faut en tenir compte alors mes chers
collègues je tiens à vous dire la seule
information qui compte à ce stade du
débat c'est que nous avons une heure
dans dans la vue nous avons monsieur
Kepel dans quelques instants et que donc
maintenant il s'agit d'être extrêmement
strict sur les temps de parole la parole
est à Monsieur fffer pour le
rassemblement
national merci monsieur le Président
merci au rapporteurs pour leur travail
important depuis le début du premier
mandat d'Emmanuel Macron la
détérioration de nos relations avec de
nombreux partenaires suscite pour nous
de profondes inquiétudes sur la place de
la France dans le monde et
particulièrement dans un continent
africain lié depuis plus de TR siècles à
notre pays cette détérioration a des
répercussions profondes sur notre
sécurité sur l'avenir de l'Afrique
francophone et sur notre signature
diplomatique qui s'affaiblit au Maghreb
les multiples tentatives de
rapprochement de Paris avec Alger depuis
2017 se sont toutes soldées par des
échecs assombrissant dans le même temps
nos échanges avec Raba nos relations
avec le Maroc pays le plus stable et le
plus francophile du Maghreb ont rarement
été aussi orageuses parallèlement la
France fait face à un recul sans
précédent au Sahel et un sentiment
antif-rançais de plus en plus virulent
cette fin d'année marquera d'ailleurs un
terme à la présence militaire française
dans toute la région malgré les succès
de nos armées au cours des trois
dernières années seulement l'Afrique a
connu SEP coups d'états réussis dont
deux ont eu lieu ces trois derniers mois
nos troupes ont dû se retirer du Mali du
Burkina Faso de la République
centrafricaine malgré le sacrifice de 58
de nos militaires français morts en
opération visant à assurer la sécurité
de la région ce weekend encore 22
casques bleus de l'ONU ont été blessés
par des engins explosifs au Mali le
Tchad ne tient que par la force des
armes face à ces réalités il apparaît
nécessaire que la France développe une
politique poursuivant principalement le
développement ses relations économiques
vous l'avez rappelé les échanges sont
particulièrement dynamiques avec les
pays littoraux tels que le Sénégal la
Côte d'Ivoire le Gabon le nigéa ou
encore l'Angola qui qui constittu des
partenaires importants pour notre pays
une politique littorale permettrait de
s'ouvrir davantage à l'Afrique
anglophone et lusophone une ouverture
aujourd'hui insuffisante comme vous le
précdez dans le rapport mais notre
stratégie doit aussi inclure les pays
sahéliens et enclavés qui souhaite
entenir entretenir une coopération de
qualité avec la France je pense tout
particulièrement au Tchad avec la
coopération militaire est constante en
tant que nation historiquement proche du
Maghreb et de l'Afrique de l'Ouest en
raison de lien culturel et stratégique
et au regard la situation actuelle il
est impératif que la France révise sa
position et réorganise sa feuille de
route diplomatique de nouvelles
alliances pourraient être créées sur une
base commune et c'est un un des
objectifs de la Déclaration des droits
des peuples et des nations lancé par
Marine Le Pen en septembre dernier
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
mentionné dans vos préconisations la
nécessité pour la France d'assumer ses
intérêts en Afrique vous vous expliquez
aussi qu'il convient de
AF alors que la démographie africaine
suit une courbe exponentielle alors que
notre politique d'immigration n' jamais
été aussi laxiste et que l'insécurité
qui en découle dans notre pays explose
êtes-vous réellement convaincu que
faciliter la délivrance de visa sans en
renforcer les critères d'attribution
servirait au final les intérêts de la
France je vous remercie c'est une
question ponctuelle vous y
répondz je vais répondre là-dessus
rapidement on on suggère de transformer
le mode d'attribution des visas dans le
respect des flux je P dans la contrainte
et la maîtrise des flux c'est très clair
là-dessus il y a pas de de décalage avec
Michel Tabarot sur ce planl ce qu'on
veut dire c'est que la France se un crée
desatisfaction de gens qui 10 personnes
20 personnes m'ont dit on ne dépose même
plus de demande de visa parce qu'on a
peur d'être humilié par cette façon de
de de donner des des visas vous avez
Michel l'a dit le le major euh en
terminal du lycée mermose d'Abidjan
auquel on refuse un visa pour faire ses
études il fait ses études euh en en au
Canada vous avez une chef d'entreprise à
à Abidjan qui veut acheter du matériel
en France qui demande des visas pour
former son personnel en France pendant
quelques semaines on lui refuse de visa
au personnel elle est partie en Inde
acheter le matériel euh des voilà sur
les le le le vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale du Cameroun euh
qui vient faire un un un colloque sur la
Francophonie avec un visa avec un
passeport diplomatique une note verbale
de son ministère et auquel on refuse le
visa donc il y a des incohérences
totales on prend bien sûr les cas
extrêmes toujours mais la longueur le
temps d'attente vous allez à Dakar faut
passer par une plateforme privée ces
gens de la plateforme privée se font
rémunérés vous devez payer pour avoir un
un rendez-vous dans 3 semaines parfois 2
mois parfois il y a pas de rendez-vous
dans les de mois qui suivent donc il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont on
n'est pas dans la politique on est dans
la capacité à mettre en œuvre un service
public qui sur les visas dysfonctionne
pas de transparence et donc ça nous
pénalise ça qu'on veut dire mais on
maîtrise les flux bien évidemment
excusez-moi un mot simplement préciser
donc vous avez évoqué la situation de du
Maghreb on a volontairement sorti le le
Maghreb de de notre étude parce qu'on
rentrait dans dans quelque chose
d'encore beaucoup plus large et je
partage votre avis j'ai eu l'occasion de
poser une question au au gouvernement
dans ce sens les les erreurs du
gouvernement d'avoir souhaité absolument
favoriser les liens avec l'Algérie de
s'être fait claquer la porte onné de
nombreuses fois alors qu'on a détérioré
nos relations avec le Maroc qui est un
un partenaire
fidèle sur le les problèmes de notre
armée on rappelle qu'il y a eu de deux
élénements on en parlera peut-être tout
à l'heure à travers d'autres d'autres
questions mais il y a eu on a perdu des
des hommes effectivement on a été appelé
et on a éé é des des partenaires loyaux
et et on a réussi l'opération Serval
l'opération barkane a été beaucoup plus
compliquée pour nous et on voit qu'il y
a eu une difficulté de sortie politique
pour arrêter avant et faire comprendre
aux population que les représentants
locaux etc le G5 Sael ne faisait pas le
travail qu'il était censé faire enfin
sur le sur les visas je partage
totalement ce qu' ce qu'a dit mon mon
collègue Bruno ça n'est pas pour ouvrir
des vannes migration incontrôlé c'est au
contraire lorsqu'il y a des profils très
spécifiques qui se font claquer
plusieurs fois la poronnaé avec des
représentants du gouvernement euh des
professeurs des chercheurs et tout ça
c'est simplement de se dire que ces
personnes-là qui sont des relais
essentiel pour pour la France euh se
voyant refusé et
humilier sur sur les visas euh garde
beaucoup d'amertume c'est le cas
d'ailleurs au Maroc où j'étais enfin où
on on rencontre ces mêmes difficultés
donc on se pose des questions sur tout
ce qui a été externalisé qui est une
grande fragilité pour nous aujourd'hui
merci merci Madame madame le rapporteur
on est vraiment très très très à la Bour
pour la France insoumise monsieur legal
qui va faire preuve de son sa brièveté
légendaire 2 minutes et
demi merci monsieur le Président merci
madame et monsieur le rapporteur merci
pour ce rapport nous nous voterons pour
la publication de ce rapport parce que
même si on n'est pas d'accord avec tout
ce qu'il y a dedans il il a le mérite de
porter un débat il a le mérite de
d'avoir une d'offrir une synthèse assez
claire de la situation et il a le mérite
de porter un débat parce que je moi je
suis pas d'accord avec ce qui avait été
dit précédemment ce n'est pas vrai qu'il
y a eu un débat sur les choix
stratégiques majeurs pris par la France
depuis longtemps et notamment depuis
2017 mais même avant et le seul débat
finalement c'était tout est de la faute
des autres euh alors que les autres les
10 autres hein les Russes les Chinois et
d'autres acteurs finalement ne faisaient
que s'engouffrer euh dans des failles
euh de notre stratégie ou de notre
absence de stratégie alors s'il y a au
moins plusieurs points avec lesquels on
est en accord c'est sur l'importance de
l'Afrique euh l'importance à venir et
l'importance passé euh vous avez rappelé
les le poids des chiffres notamment en
terme de population si on se coupe de la
relation avec l'Afrique sur le 21e
siècle on est hors jeu faut être très
clair là-dessus euh donc faut sortir des
visions rabougeris basé sur la peur du
grand remplacement et cetera et et et
offrir une autre vision c'est pas par
hasard si en Afrique il y a par parmi
les grands leaders al TER mondialistes
ils étaient en Afrique j'aurais un point
de désaccord avec vous c'est que
l'Afrique ça fait longtemps qu'elle est
dans la mondialisation sauf qu'elle en
connaît pas la bonne facette quand vous
dites elle vient de rentrer non ça fait
longtemps qu'elle est dedans même
l'esclavage c'est de la
mondialisation
et il faut absolument une vision
alternative à la vision purement
militaire moi je je dis pas qu'il faut
pas des emprises militaires mais il faut
une vision alternative parce que ça ne
peut pas reposer que là-dessus et le
succès tactique les succès tactiques
qu'on a pu connaître au Sahel et je
rends hommage à chaque fois aux 58
soldats qui ont perdu la vie n'enlève
rien au fait que politiquement on a subi
une défaite stratégique et c'est pas moi
qui le dis c'est encore monsieur de
Villepin qui le disait récemment c'est
une défaite stratégique au Sahel et donc
voilà sur la question des valeurs euh il
faut en sortir avec le double standard
c'est clair on peut pas d'un côté
approuver des billes au Chad et de
l'autre côté dénoncer les coups d'État
au Mali là-bas ils le voient les gens et
enfin sur la question des moyens c'est
fondamental de rappeler qu'on pourra on
peut avoir toutes les stratégies du
monde on pourra rien faire si on
rétablit pas la barre moin 40 %
d'effectifs du kedoré en Afrique depuis
les années 2000 c'est un vrai sujet sur
les visas on peut avoir toutes les
coopérations du monde si on donne pas le
visa aux universitaires et cetera au
moment clé même même au au politique
voilà et dernier point juste un gros
point de désaccord avec ce que j'ai pu
dire dans le sur un point qui n'est pas
un détail en une seconde je reviens de
la République desmque du Congo écrire
que le Rwanda est la porte d'entrée en
RDC c'est une erreur majeure je veux pas
rentrer les détail parce que tout est
tout est pas de la faute de la du Randa
bien ça c'est un débat qu'on ouvrira
plus
tardercie je vous remercie les les le
lequel des des rapporteurs
souhaite vous pouvez couper votre micro
s'il vous plaît monsieur legal merci oui
d'abord je parler de mondialisation j'ai
dit de parler de d'un continent qui
était entré en en concurrence dans
lequel d'autres pays venaient ce qui
était pas le cas il y a encore quelques
quelques dizaines d'années donc je pas
fait référence à ça euh effectivement on
a un volet important de rapport et des
propositions on va peut-être prendre
quelques secondes pour les les détailler
si on on diminue nos emprises militaires
si on diminue le poids du politique il
faut bien le remplacer par quelque chose
et donc il faut massivement réintégrer
le terrain réinvestir le terrain mettre
des des des des des personnes
d'expertise sur le terrain massivement
et ça passe par une transformation de de
l'idée qu'on a de euh des
investissements solidaires de l'APD tel
qu'on le le dit ou disait ça veut dire
également une transformation des modes
d'action de l'AFD qui doit être beaucoup
plus à financer des projets direct
beaucoup plus sur euh aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que c'est encore très très long à
mettre en œuvre il faut 3 ans 4 ans pour
un projet de l'AFD d'être misise en
œuvre et donc les populations et c'est
là-dessus peut-être que je peux faire un
point aujourd'hui vous prenez l'exemple
du du Gabon qui qui est symptomatique
euh on dépense des milliards d'euros en
aide au développ
les gens sur le terrain vous disent on
ne voit pas cette aide on la voit pas
non pas tant parce qu'elle n'arrive pas
mais parce qu'elle n'est pas identifiée
France donc il pense que la elle
n'arrive pas pour eux ça n'arrive pas et
donc bien sûr ils pensent que cette aide
est détournée et donc ça crée une
mauvaise image en conséquence il pense
que cette elle va au profit des
dirigeants du pays donc il faut
absolument communiquer comme l'a dit
Michel Tabarot très différemment sur des
des petits projets des projets taille
moyenne mais directement aux opérateurs
pour qu'on montre tout ce que la France
euh fait voilà merci vous
avezich vous avez é le double standard
vous avez raison aujourd'hui il y a
forcément une frustration lorsqu'on
traite d'une façon un pays enfin les les
les événements de ce pays et et
lorsqu'on les traite autrement dans dans
d'autres pays donc ça aussi c'est un
travail à faire sur sur nous de savoir
quels sont nos nos règles qu'est-ce
qu'on définit comme standard et et de
veiller à appliquer les mêmes règles
dans dans tous les pays quel que soient
nos nos intérêts je pense que c'est
important important pour avoir cette
crédibilité vis-à-vis des des Africains
en dehors de
ça c'est c'est d'être très visible sur
nos actions malheureusement beaucoup de
d'argent mais enfin on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en parler avec un pilotage
qui n'est pas politique et et
malheureusement qui manque dans les
ambassades au niveau des des actions
culturelles au niveau de différents
domaines pour mettre en place vraiment
une image de partenariat entre la France
et Les Afriques nous aurons un débat sur
cette question bientôt je vous remercie
pour les républicains michel Herbillon
Michel votre talent en 2 minutes et
demi merci 2 minutes 35 de bonneheure
pour reprendre une chanson célèbre je
vous remercie beaucoup pour mes chers
collègues rapporteurs pour la qualité la
densité de votre raort d'information
consacré en relation entre la France et
l'Afrique nous mesurons l'important
travail produit et j'espère que votre
rapport d'information sera un élément
déterminant dans la reconstruction d'une
offre stratégique crédible de la France
dans ce continent voisin en effet votre
rapport dresse le constat implacable du
recul de la France en Afrique un
continent en pleine mutation dont notre
pays n'a pas su comprendre les besoins
nouveaux aussi pour bâtir une nouvelle
politique africaine de la France vous
préconisez un changement de méthode tout
d'abord en cessant d'imposer notre
grille de lecture sur ce continent
complexe qui impose de mieux appréhender
les aspirations des populations
notamment de sa jeunesse et ses besoins
un changement de style surtout où les
grands discours grandiloquant n'ont fait
qu'alimenter la déception de nos
partenaires africains enfin vous appelz
à clarifier notre doctrine pour que la
France mobilise davantage ses atouts
stratégique et notamment clarifie vous
en avez parlé sa politique des visas
alors ma première question au sujet de
l'aide publique au développement que
préconisez-vous pour réformer en
profondeur la stratégie et le pilotage
politique de l'AFD et quelles sont les
réponses que vous avez eu du
gouvernement ou de la gouvernance de la
de la suite à vos préconisations
parce que ça fait longtemps que dans
cette commission nous dénonçons la façon
dont est conduite la politique de l'AFD
la deuxième question fort de votre
travail très approfondi je tiens à
souligner je voudrais savoir quels sont
selon vous les principales conditions à
réunir pour redresser la situation et
pour permettre à la France de retrouver
une place sur le continent africain
quelles sont les actions prioritaires
que vous préconisez et comment rendre
lisible une politique qui apparaît
aujourd'hui incohérente pour cela
faut-il selon vous décloisonner ce
domaine réservé du président de la
République pour associer plus largement
le gouvernement français les
parlementaires les diplomates et
l'ensemble des experts enfin une
dernière question plus spécifiquement
pour Michel Tabarot vous évoquez cher
Michel la mobilisation des Russes des
Turcs des Chinois ou encore des
israéliens dans la formation militaire
et sécuritaire vous souligner que la
France n'a pas suffisamment identifié
les attentes stratégiques de nos
partenaires africain
comment renforcer la position de la
France en ce domaine et en quoi cela est
indispensable pour notre base
industrielle et technologique de défense
je vous remercie je voulais dire
monsieur le Président que nous voterons
pour pour la diffusion de ce rapport la
publication du rapport je tiens
d'ailleurs à préciser je le préciserai
au moment du vote qu'il ne s'agit pas de
voter pour ou contre le rapport mais
pour ou contre sa sa
publication qui veut commencer Michel
peut-être c'est à vous de commencer je
commence avec plaisir pour répondre à
mon collègue michelbillon qui BRI oui
qui qui connaît bien toutes ces toutes
ces thématiques sur sur la
partie du pilotage politique moi je
reste persuadé que que le seul
conseiller Afrique est est trop peu pour
pour ce ce territoire on a connu avant
des ministres de la coopération il y
avait un lien particulier il y avait un
gros travail qui était fait en amont et
qui permettait ensuite de se rapprocher
bien entendu du président qui reste le
décideur en en matière de politique
international donc avoir un un conseil
avec à la fois un ministre de la
Coopération qu'on appellerait ministre
des partenariat puisque c'est le choix
du président et ensuite pouvoir y
installer autour de la table tous les
les les ministres acteurs de de qui
peuvent intervenir sur sur l'Afrique ça
me semble très important et ne pas
oublier la représentation par je pense
que c'est important nous avons tous des
réseaux on a quelques collègues qui
s'occupent de la Francophonie qui se
font des déplacements dans dans certains
pays vous venez d'en faire un récemment
monsieur legal également et tout ça je
pense que que le l'action concertée
entre le Parlement et le gouvernement me
paraît une démarche importante ensuite
sur l'AFD on a peu à peu abandonner le
pilotage politique de l'AFD et on on
s'en rend compte les ambassadeurs s'en
plaignent le le l'action de la France
n'est pas reconnue si ça avait été
efficace et bien on accepterait la
nouvelle formule mais on investit
aujourd aujourd'hui 5 milliards d'euros
dans un continent qui est en train de
nous claquer la porte au nez parce que
concrètement lorsqu'on participe à des
actions financièrement lafd disparaît
avec tout un tas de de bailleurs et on
ne sait pas lorsque vous traversez une
route et bien on ne sait pas que c'est
la France qui permet à cette route
d'être réalisée et et je crois qu'on
doit reprendre les choses en main sur le
plan politique sur le plan de la
communication et que les médias aussi je
l'ai évoqué reléent les actions positive
de la France ça aidera bien entendu les
populations à à apprécier la France
d'une autre façon je merci est-ce que
Bruno a quelque chose à ajouter c'est
pas nécessaire
Bruno j'ai pas mal de choses à à ajouter
mais je vais passer la main très bien
mais tu ne per rien pour attendre n ne
perdons rien pour attendre c'est
maintenant madame Dar pour le pour le
groupe modem qui va je c'est à
vous merci Monsieur le présid
Président chers collègues bon alors ce
rapport peut paraître à certains sévère
il est d'ailleurs dans dans certains
terme mais en définitive c'est bien de
bousculer euh pour faire avancer je
crois qu'il faut quelquefois bon voilà
pouvoir pouvoir dire les choses parce
que au moins on le lit et au moins on
est interpellé donc
euh ce n'est pas inutile euh bon
beaucoup de merci pour ce rapport et
pour son exhaustivité et puis je trouve
que c'est bien d'avoir envisagé
l'Afrique dans son ensemble et pas voilà
pas pays par pays parce que j'ai été
frappé pour avoir été souvent dans ces
ces pays et avoir assisté à à
d'importantes réunions o où où des tous
les pays africains étaient présents en
fait de le la concordance de de de leur
souhait de de parler Afrique en général
et et je trouve que ça c'est c'est
quelque chose que vous avez bien
appréhandé on parle de de sécurité et de
nos armées qui ont été très présentes
bien sûr moi je je j'estime et nous
estimons tous que Serval et barcan ça a
été à la demande des Africains et on
s'est retiré à leur demande également
donc notre voilà nous n'avons pas été ni
ni inquisiteur ni je crois que nous
avons tenu notre rôle et fait ce que
demandaient les Africains donc il
faudrait peut-être rendre acte de cela à
la France et puis notre présence en
terme de sécurité elle est importante
aussi aujourd'hui par exemple dans le
Golfe de Guinée où nous sommes là euh
présents pour assurer la sécurité contre
la pêche illégale et la piraterie et la
pêche illégale c'est ce qui est en train
potentiellement d'enlever des ressources
euh alimentaire à l'Afrique dans ce dans
ce domaine-là donc je crois que là aussi
on nous attend dans certains dans
certains domaines et nous sommes nous
sommes les les bienvenus donc il faut
pondérer tout ça et et et juger tout ça
à à l'ône de euh de de des des intérêts
des uns et des autres ceci dit la
difficulté vient également euh et vous
l'avez noter bon des des changements
politiques brutaux qui ne sont pas des
changements démocratiques auxquels on
est habitué bien entendu et il faut
s'adapter à ces situations et euh là
vous avez très bien analysé les choses
et ma question elle elle est simple
comment pouvons-nous avancer
positivement c'est dans la communication
euh nous avons été débord par une
communication
antiançaisezbordé votre porté par les
par les Russes en
particulier de façon très Activ et je
l'ai vu sur le terrain nous devons être
non seulement nousons pas rester en
position défensive mais en position
offensive moi je suis en position
offensive et je donne la parole à
Monsieur fou ce qui fera une
transition politique merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre oui tout à fait c'est ce que
j'ai dit on est dans une position
aujourd'hui de rôle subi et donc il faut
revenir dans un rôle choisi donc il faut
une offre stratégique claire on propose
des éléments pour la construire on
propose justement la création d'un
comité très large franco-africain avec
des experts pour définir justement quel
peut-être notre doctrine et et et la la
la la compléter et
l'affiner je ne pense pas que le rapport
soit sévère le rapport il est réaliste
tout ce qu'on dit dans le rapport a été
entendu c'est ce qu'on dit en Afrique
alors on peut se VO et la face on peut
dire que tout va bien non non mais je
mais mais il n'est pas sévère loin de là
euh il faut coordonner beaucoup plus nos
efforts par exemple quand vous avez une
association ou des associations en Côte
d'Ivoire qui vous disent que soit ne
répondent pas aux appels d'offre parce
que il faut 8 mois 1 an de procédure
pour avoir 1500 ou 2000 € soit elles
répondent à des appels à projet mais
quel ce n'est pas l'objet de leur
association mais elles vont sur les
appels à projet parce que elles ont
besoin de financement donc elles ne font
pas ce pourquoi elles ont créé leur
association et elles vous disent bon
voilà vous on n'est plus dans une
période coloniale mais on est dans dans
un une sorte période post-coloniale où
vous voulez coloniser culturellement
l'Afrique c'est des choses qu'on entend
tous les jours en Afrique donc il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont pour
que nous on on sache quel est l'état de
la situation on a perdu depuis 20 ans la
connaissance que l'on a affiné de
l'Afrique on vous propose là par un
nombre de de témoignage et d'analyse de
dire de voir c'est pas nous qui le
disons c'est qu'est-ce que on dit de
nous en Afrique si on ne n'est pas
conscient de ça on ne peut pas
réactualiser notre logiciel et répondre
aux attentes qui se
posent juste un petit mot pardon
concernant nos nos armées donc
premièrement l'opération Corre parfaite
j'avais l'occasion de d'être rapporteur
sur sur sur le budget et j'avais choisi
ce sujet parce que c'est vraiment très
très important deuxièmement sur Serval
ça a été effectivement une réussite sur
Barkan les enjeux qui étaient demandés
étaient particulièrement compliqués
parce que malheureusement nous avons été
abandonnés par les partenaires qui
devaient prendre le relais et donc il y
a une sortie un petit peu compliquée qui
laisse le sentiment que barkam n'a pas
été une réussite et vous avez très bien
fait de le rappeler nous étions là à la
demande des Africains et pas avec une
une volonté de de d'agir seul donc on a
et c'est important et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons souhaité é les
auditionnés Wagner aussi alors même si
on peut pas mettre toutes les
difficultés de la France aujourd'hui sur
le dos des Russes et de Wagner mais ils
ont su et ils savent encore on l'a vu
sur le Niger puisque c'était eux qui
finançaient les manifestants devant
l'ambassade de France on sait très bien
qu'il joue un rôle avec d'autres acteurs
qui sont présents qui sont plus discrets
mais nous avons des Turcs nous avons des
Chinois qui ont des intérêts et qui ne
facilite pas les choses pour la France
Merci Merci
euh maintenant pour les socialistes et
apparentè c'est monsieur le député de la
Gironde Monsieur David merci monsieur le
Président Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues merci tout
d'abord pour ce rapport qui fera date
sur cette question des relation entre la
France et l'Afrique ou Les
Afriques qui est souvent qui est souvent
présente dans nos
débat merci également de ne pas avoir
gommé vos divergences qui témoigne de
l'utilité du travail
parlementaire loin d'être caricaturaux
ou contre-productifs nos débats
politiques y compris sur ces questions
internationales sont au contraire
constructifs lorsque les positions
politiques sont assumées avec
intelligence et avec une volonté
d'émulation
intellectuelle j'ai évidemment pris
bonne note de votre analyse initiale sur
les causes profonde et plus
circonstantielle de cette distance
croissante entre la France et les pays
africain j'ai également pris bonne note
des propositions et des pistes de
réflexion de l'un et de l'autre de nos
corapporteurs devant l'ampleur de cette
question nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir très régulièrement sur le sujet
très prochainement je pense mais je me
consacrerai pour ma part ce matin au
sujet de l'audioovuel extérieur à mes
yeux cet outil précieux pour la France
euh précieux sur sur le plan de
l'information du rayonnement de notre
pays et je sais que cette appréciation
est largement partagée et ce cet
audiovisuel reste insuffisamment
mobilisé vous l'écrivez les audiences
des antennes de France méia monde en
Afrique sont très satisfaisantes au vu
des moyens bien moindres dont elle
bénéficie par rapport à leur
concurrentes quelle piste spécifique
permettrai à notre audio visuel de mieux
défendre l'image de la France et de
notre diplomatie dans les pays africains
merci merci monsieur le député lequel
madame Tabarot oui je veux bien très
bien si tu veux couper ton c'est fa
voilà non pas encore c'est pasur c'est
pas allez-y ah qu'est-ce qu'il y
a c'est vous qui avez voilà très bienon
voilà euh Monsieur David donc mon cher
collègue effectivement l'Audiovisuel
Extérieur de la France est très
important pour nos relations en Afrique
nous sommes très très écouté très suivi
et je dirais que c'est à la fois
important pour l'Afrique et ensuite pour
la diaspora donc ça ça a un double
intérêt vous avez parlé des des moyens
on peut toujours en discuter pour voir
si si des
moyens sont suffisants aujourd'hui ou
s'il faut les les développer moi c'est
sur la sur la dém marche que je voudrais
appuyer parce que ça nous a été dit très
régulièrement sur place par les
Africains qui nous ont dit vous donnez
une image de la France c'està-d que
c'est considéré comme finalement la voix
de du gouvernement et et vous et et le
fait d'entendre sans arrêt donc les
critiques plutôt que de valoriser
l'action aussi de la France ça donne le
sentiment voilà que la que la France ne
fait pas grand-chose pour pour l'Afrique
nous avons de bons projets qui sont Ré
isé dans le cadre des des moyens qui
sont qui sont mis à la FD et ça n'est
pas relayé nous avons lorsqu'il y a une
agitation dans un dans un pays où les
jeintes sont en train de de prendre le
pouvoir et et utilisé par par Wagner
malheureusement on ne va écouter que
ceux qui qui qui en ont après la France
mais qui sont payés même on nous l'a
confirmé pour venir manifester avec des
drapeaux russes devant l'ambassade de
France donc et alors qu'on nous expque
de façon un petit peu plus large à côté
il y a il y a un soutien de la France et
un amour de la France donc on entend pas
ces deux voix et finalement le le
l'audiovisuel devient un petit peu la
caisse de résonance de ceux qui essaient
de nous déstabiliser donc on a un gros
travail à faire sur sur
l'information sur pour lutter aussi
contre la désinformation et et utiliser
ce qui est du soft power le France
méiaamonde
autrement une phrase Bruno oui les
journalistes français travaillent comme
un service public d'information donc
avec toute liberté or en Afrique comme
c'est des médias euh français on pense
c'est des médias
d'étatétat donc voilà la confusion elle
vient de là et c'est ce que je voulais
préciser c'est c'est très clair je vous
remercie euh monsieur portarieux pour
horizon
merci président euh depuis de deux
décennies à peu près la Chine investit
beaucoup en
en Afrique pour s'assurer notamment le
contrôle d'une grande partie des métau
critiques selon plusieurs spécialistes
l'investissement s'élève sur cette
période à près de 150 milliards de
dollars sur la période 2005 2021 comme
l'a notamment souligné Bruno fou notre
corrapporteur dont je partage totalement
l'analyse les Chinois exploitent par
exemple presque toutes les mines de
cobalt de la République démocratique du
Congo qui concentre à elle seu 70 % de
cette ressource mondiale et cet élément
comme comme vous le savez est absolument
indispensable à la fabrication des
batteries
électriques quand on sait que la
consommation de cobalt va être multiplié
par 20 d'ici 2040 on prend conscience de
des enjeux et c'est la même tendance
avec à peu près tous les métos rares
comme le nickel le graphite ou encore le
lithium le lithium c'est pire puisque
que les besoins vont exploser dans les
10 prochaines années alors face à cette
omniprésence de la Chine sur le
continent africain le réveil de l'Europe
et de la France en particulier n'est-il
pas un peu trop
tardif monsieur fou maintenant les les
les rapporteurs vont je vais donner la
parole à un seul rapporteur sauf une
toute
petiteaire du second parce que sinon
nous nous allons vraiment nous brouiller
avec Monsieur Keppel merci pour votre
président décontractez-vous merci oui
regardez la liste regardez la liste des
particulier oui merci pour votre
question c'est un point c'est un point
central euh quand on voit les
montants investis mobilisés par nos
concurrents ce n'est pas l'aide au
développement française malgré le fait
qu'on l'a très sensiblement augmenté qui
va résoudre la question et du
développement en Afrique et justement de
la question de la souverereaineté de nos
propres économies parce que pouvoir
passer des partenariats économiques en
Afrique ou d'exploitation sur sur les
mines c'est aussi assurer notre
souveraineté oui il faut absolument
développer l'économie on a fait un
nombre de de propositions la question
qui qui est un frein important c'est que
depuis la loi Sapin 2 que bien sûr on
soutient évidemment les critères qui
sont nécessaires pour exploiter
une de de l'industrie ou ou ou ou une
mine c'est vrai pour tous les les
groupes côtés au 4 40 sont extrêmement
contraignants et donc il y a une
différence de de de de niveau de de
concurrence où les Chinois n'ont pas du
tout les mêmes contrainte que les
Français et donc les groupes français
européens mais français aussi quittent
pour une partie l'Afrique au Niger avant
même le le coup d'État euh il total
était parti orange était parti et C qui
est pas côté mais Castel le brasseur
était parti donc c'est vrai les PME
peuvent venir plus mais les grands
groupes pour cette raisonl faud trouver
une solution pour garantir les questions
bien sûr de de d'exploitation d'éthique
de nos et nos pratiques industrielle
mais aussi permettre d'avoir une
concurrence soit pas aussi faussée car
on ne peut pas faire concurrence dans
cette dans ce cadre là avec les Chinois
merci Michel juste juste un petit mot
mot je pense que les Africains sont en
train de d'en revenir un petit peu sur
par rapport au aux Chinois qui sont en
train de de les piller et et ils
utilisent en plus une méthode terrible
avec la dette donc ils réalisent des
infrastructures et lorsqu'il y a des
difficultés de de paiement il décident
de bloquer d'autres infrastructures on a
l'exemple du Kenya où ils sont en train
de de réaliser des infrastructure assez
importante et si le Kenya ne les paie
pas ils ont décidé de récupérer le port
de Monbassa donc à force aujourd'hui
enfin jusqu'à présent c'était pas
visible et il pensaiit que c'était un
investisseur intéressant aujourd'hui les
Africains commence à réaliser que c'est
plutôt un prédateur voilà je vous
remercie vous avez tout à fait raison
nous avons mis 140 ans à lasser les
Africains les Chinois font beaucoup plus
vite euh monsieur Lecoq pour la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine mon cher
vice-président merci monsieur le
Président je sais pas si en fait j'ai
hésité à à ne pas prendre la parole pour
euh pour éviter de perdre du temps pour
éviter de perdre du temps bah oui parce
que c'est ça fait quand même un moment
que que les questions africaines sont
sont posé euh on parle vous parlez à
plusieurs reprises dans le rapport du
continent africain continent africain
mais vous avez choisi de ne pas étudier
tout le continent africain euh en
laissant la partie Nord notamment et
c'est pas vous auriez dû quand même
mesurer que la partie nord de l'Afrique
a agit sur la mentalité de la partie sud
euh du Sahara euh ce que l'on a fait en
Libye ça a laissé des traces dans les
dans les pays de l'Afrique subsaharienne
ce que l'on a la façon dont on s'est
comporté pendant la le printemps arabe
et ce qui s'est passé en Tunisie enfin
on y a laissé une ministre nous chez
nous je veux pas dire mais des Affaires
étrangères ça a laissé des traces les
relations avec l'Algérie ça laisse des
traces l'attitude de la France vis-à-vis
du Maroc par rapport au Sahara
Occidental ça laisse des traces parce
que quand même à un moment donné tous
les pays d'Afrique sauf le Maroc
considérait qu'il fallait faire
appliquer les résolutions des Nations
Unies donc ça l' des traces alors après
le business et tout est dans certains
changer de comportement l'attitude de la
France vis-à-vis de certains dirigeants
ça laisse des traces
Bagbo et et le fait que la France
accompagne Atara en Côte d'Ivoire au
pouvoir et cetera ça laisse des traces
vous pouvez on peut pas faire comme si
tout commencé c'est pas ce que vous
faites tout commenca à une certaine date
à un moment donné les processus
historique laiss trac le Fran CFA rien
que le terme c'est un sujet quand même
pourquoi est-ce qu'on naccompagne pas
les pays africains pour créer eux-mêmes
leur propre monnaie mais non on
accompagne en disant on garde quand même
un lien franç fa donc accompagnons la la
deuxème la deuxème indépendance de
l'Afrique après l'indépendance politique
il faut maintenant l'indépendance
économique et puis agir d'égal à égal et
alors sur les visas j'ai hte de voir
l'attitude des uns et des autres au
moment de la loi immigration parce que
sur la question des visas ça va être
quelque chose un étudiant africain un
Sénégalais parce qu'il faut être précis
sénégalais qui fait des études de
physique nucléaire ou dans le cadre de
l'Université que l'on a financé que l'on
a monté le stage pratique ne peut se
faire qu'en France là où il y a des
entreprises de physique nucléaire
impossible d'avoir le visa pour terminer
donc ne peut pas être diplômé incroyable
on explique des différents acteurs comme
ça alors moi je sais que j'ai droit à
moins de 2 minutes 30 oui les autres ont
eu TR mais moi je m'arrête là
par non mais vous avez vous avez le vous
avez le ch
dilaté je vous remercie mais je sais
votre tempérance je sais votre
tempérance monsieur le vice-président et
je donne la parole à Madame Tabarot qui
brûle de vous répondre sur le francf en
particulier voà simplement vous vous
signalez enfin que le constat on l'a
fait la seule chose qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a on a exclu parce que bon vous
avez vu on a on a démarré en en mars et
et on a fini tout juste maintenant donc
si on avait rajouté les pays du Maghreb
on aurait prolongé encore cette mission
et le Président bourlange nous attendait
au tournant pour qu'on rendre rapidement
nos travaux en dehors de ça sur le Fran
CFA sur le Fran CFA le président alors
c'est moi qui le dit donc le président
Macron s'est clairement positionné en
expliquant qu'il était tout à fait
d'accord et qu'il fallait qu'il le fasse
donc on en a parlé au ministre des
Finances de Côte d'Ivoire qui nous a dit
attention ça se fait pas comme ça on a
peur des dévaluations on a peur de d'un
certain nombre de difficult
donc on le fera à notre rythme donc je
crois qu'au niveau de la France les
choses sont claires si c'est un irritant
la France est tout à fait prête à à
aider à accompagner pour cette sortie ce
ce cette suppression du CSA et cette
nous nouvelle monnaie qui pourrait être
créée et ça ne pose aucun problème à la
classe politique donc je pense que que
vous le voyez comme un comme un faux
sujet et sur les les visas j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer un un un
étudiant qui a qui a fait tout son
parcours qui a fait tout son parcours
dans un cursus français et qui souhaite
venir continuer ses études en France a
tout à fait le droit d'avoir un visa et
pourtant vous connaissez mes positions
sur sur l'immigration sur les sujets que
nous allons avoir ces jours
oui un un un tout petit mot parce
que on peut faire la stratégie que l'on
veut communiquer comme on veut si on
n'élimine pas les irritants on sera
toujours scotché comme des pavés dans
sac à dos on av'avancera pas et CETA sur
le Fran CFA il faut faire la enfin on
suggère de faire la chose suivante il
faut faire un échéancier en disant on
souhaite nous de le faire à non on
propose qu'en 2028 par exemple avec une
date précise on souhaite que les pays
africains prennent la main sur le franc
CFA et donc on renvoie comme ça le le
mytigri au pays Afric aujourd'hui on
peut plus rien faire c'est eux qui ne le
prennent pas en main il faut fixer une
échéance et les mettre devant leur
responsabilité j'ai j'ai compris qu'il y
avait un léger désaccord entre le entre
ent les deux rapporteurs l'un croit que
c'est à nous de fixer les échéances et
Madame Tabarot pense que c'est aux
Africains de le faire et c'est très bien
tout le monde a compris maintenant la la
parole est au au titre des non inscrits
à Monsieur du ponteignan merci monsieur
le Président bon ce rapport est est
extrêmement précieux je pense pour nous
tous il montre et que ça ne plaise pas
ça ne plaît pas simplement au pouvoir ça
c'est déplaisant pour tous les Français
c'est un gâi immense et vous l'expliquez
très bien alors il y a trois
contradictions que vous pointez qui sont
autant de de leçons et et de chemin pour
essayer de reconstruire parce que ce qui
est important pour nous tous ici je
crois auelà d'éclivage c'est de
reconstruire cette relation première
contradiction c'est au momentù l'Afrique
va avoir un poids considérable dans le
monde que que la franceévanouit et
réduit ses moyens alors là il va bien
falloir un moment se dire qu'est-ce
qu'on investi et et est-ce qu'on se
donne vraiment les moyens d'agir je
reviens pas là-dessus vous l'avez
expliqué mais je vois qu'il y a beaucoup
d'argent pour beaucoup de domaines et
dans beaucoup de secteurs du monde donc
c'est quand même curieux de gâcher notre
nos atouts et et d'abandonner nos atouts
le deuxième point et la deuxième
contradiction fondamentale que vous
évoquez c'est sur la multiplication des
intervenants et la dispersion et
l'absence de de cohérence mais ça on le
répète depuis des années dans cette
commission c'est un scandale absolu la
FD qui est devenu un état dans l'état
une puissance qui gâche l'argent qu'on
donne enfin comment on peut accepter
cela là la Francophonie est totalement
abandonnée on inaugure une cité à
villeercotteray mais on parle anglais
partout et on défend ceux qui parlent
anglais au lieu de parler français bref
on fait tout pour
dégoûter les Africains et les dirigeants
qui aiment la France et après on
s'étonne qui nous tourne le
dos le problème du pilotage qui est
fondamental il y avait un ministère de
la coopération qui avait une expertise
c'est pas un conseiller à l'Élysée qui
peut gérer Les Afriques c'est impossible
quel que soit le Président c'est
qualités ses défauts donc reconstruisons
une vraie administration qui connaît Les
Afriques qui connaît les dirigeants qui
les
considère le trème point
fondamental c'est quelle est la
politique et ça vous l'avez très bien
dit quelle est la vision il y avait une
vision du général de Gaulle qui avait
réussi malgré tout virage de la
décolonisation parce qu'il y avait le
droit des peuples à disposer deeux même
mais aujourd'hui on prétend ne pas
intervenir mais on fait de l'ingérence
permanente donc revenons à cela et puis
dernier point je conclurai là-dessus il
y a un problème plus global vis-à-vis du
Sud du Sud global parce que le recul il
est pas simplement en Afrique je le vois
au Brésil les pays du Sud sont déçus de
l'alignement systématique de la France
sur les États-Unis de la perte
d'indépendance de notre pays du fait
qu'il y a plus une voie libre qui défend
un autre monde et c'est quand même un
paradoxe incroyable que le général de
Gaulle au moment du clivage Est-Ouest
invente le monde multipolaire au moment
où le monde multipolaire est là la
France est év et n'est que le petit le
petit soldat des Américains je vous
rappelle simplement nous avons quand
même voté sur le MoyenOrient la
résolution proposée par le par le
Brésil ce que les États-Unis n'ont pas
fait monsieur c'est c'est lequel des
deux rapporteurs qui qui répond monsieur
du poignant Voon alors Monsieur monsieur
F commencez alors je vais je vais
commencer rapidement ça sur les moyens
il y a des moyens il faut les utiliser
mieux et de façon straté
quand vous êtes un acteur dans un pays
africain vous avez 4 5 si portes
d'entrée pour aller chercher des
partenariat donc il faut c'est ce qu'on
propose que l'ambassadeur de France faut
simplifier les choses soit clair soit
autorité autorité sur l'ensemble des
services et des administrations et et
des acteurs français c'est clair et sur
les visas on résout la question vous
allez au Gabon l'ambassadeur du Gabon
ben il a autorité sur les visas il fait
voilà au moin les choses sont claires
voilà sur lafd je partage pas votre
point de vue lafd fonctionne très bien
en fonction du cahier des charges qu'on
lui a donné il y a pas de pilotage
politique suffisant voilà donc il faut
que lafd serve la stratégie française
mais la FD telle qu'elle a été dotée et
fonctionne très bien
euh voilà pour pas être trop long ce que
je pouvais dire et laisser Michel t
madame madame tavaro un mot de
ponctuation petite nuance donc avec mon
mon collègue je pense que l'AFD n'a pas
de pilotage politique du tout voilà
c'est pas que c'est peu c'est pas et et
donc sur ce que vous avez évoqué qui me
semble très juste c'est véritablement de
travailler sur une filière Afrique au
sein du qu d'orsé c'est de préparer nos
ambassadeurs parce qu'on envoie des
ambassadeurs qui ne sont pas préparés
c'est d'avoir des des Hautes Études sur
sur l'Afrique pour préparer aussi c'est
c'est un travail de longue haline mais
qui nous permettra de reprendre la main
sur sur les pays africain de reprendre
la main sur nos relations avec les pays
africains je précise bien je vous je
vous remercie nous avons terminé nous
avons terminé l'échange avec les groupes
j'ai quelques j'ai quelques
parlementaires même assez nombreux qui
se sont inscrits évidemment la liste est
close mais alors ce sera une minute
chacun et quant au rapporteurs il il y
aura un seul rapporteur qui répondra et
si le second n'est pas content de ce
qu'a dit le premier s'il veut dire autre
chose il le dira la fois suivante quand
ce sera son tour bon la première
parlementaire à parler c'est Mireille
clapau qui à qui je donne la parole
madame la député de laadrome c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président bon
beaucoup de choses a été dites moi je
considère que ce rapport c'est un un
excellent travail mais c'est une
introduction comment est-ce qu'on peut
écrire des mots justes sur notre
relation avec un continent aussi divers
alors que depuis 2017 puisque je suis
député depuis 2017 les initiatives ont
foisonné les puissances étrangères ont
conquis du terrain les vecteurs
d'influence ne sont plus les mêmes les
diasporas ont eu des signes de
reconnaissance donc je pense que même si
ce rapport est très intéressant ça ne
peut être qu'un début euh en une minute
il est difficile de commenter un travail
aussi foisonnant donc je vais me centrer
sur deux questions d'abord l'angle des
femmes vous savez que j'y suis sensible
je regrette que ce rapport n'est pas
approfondit cette question du droit des
femmes parce que s'il y a une région du
monde où ces enjeux du droit des femmes
sont fondateurs c'est bien c'est
et l'le numérique qui est aujourd'hui à
la fois certes un axe de désinformation
mais aussi un formidable til
d'émancipation économique je de 3
minutes n reconnaissons votre passion et
votre
expertise qu'est-ce qui répond c'est
c'est
Bruno vous avez éteint votre qu'est-ce
qui s'est encore
passé voilà ça va voilà bon merci pour
ces questions je je je plaide coupable
on on n'a pas pu envisager tous les
champs sur lesquels on aurait pu laisser
tellement danse riches et tellement de
de de pays d'acteurs dans chacun des
pays qu'on n pas pu développer ces
questionsl mais je l'ai dit en en préant
le Bul ça fait partie euh des éléments
extrêmement forts que la France propose
euh au aux partenairees Africains ils
savent très bien que sur ces DIMENSIONSL
et en ça la francophonie doit aider
fortement le développement de ces deux
sujets ils savent très bien qu'avec la
France on peut parler on a beaucoup de
programme justement qui
défendent la la place des femmes dans un
un un
environnement social culturel dans
lequel il y a la polygamie est très
répandue dans lequel la femme n'a pas la
place qu'elle mérite donc oui on l'a pas
développé mais ça fait partie des choses
importantes que la France est capable
d'apporter et c'est un avantage
comparatif majeur de la France par
rapport à je vous remercie parfait
monsieur bilongo une minute c'est très
rapide B merci au
corapporteur pour ce rapport de qualité
j'aimerais revenir sur la zone des
grands lacs où il y a un partenariat
militaire affiché avec le Burundi
l'Uganda et le Rwanda de la part de la
France et également un partenariat avec
la République démocratique du Congo et
en plein recrudesence des combats à
l'est de la RDC avec le groupe du M23
qui est où des rapports de l'ONU ont
attesté que le Rwanda soutient
militairement euh l'intrusion des
rebelles en territoire de RDC j'aimerais
savoir comment euh nous allons pouvoir
nous en sortir et la parole de la France
est entendu comme le Congo est le plus
grand pays francophone les USA ont
emboité le pas
avec la recherche d'une solution
diplomatique entre la RDC et le et le
Rwanda mais la France n fait rien
j'étais avec mon collègue arm legal à
Goma sur l'est de RDC nous avons fait un
voyage avec juste je termine juste
quelques secondes je termine on Fa un
voyage avec l'ONG Programme alimentaire
mondial et l'absence de la France sur
les financements du PAM nous ont
été je vous remercie c'est un énorme
problème que vous posez très passionnant
essentiel on pourra pas le traiter en
une minute mais c'est à nouveau monsieur
monsieur F oui oui mais on alterneès
bienorsob madame Tabarot est
uneapporteur généreuse
non non alors trois trois éléments euh
d'abord on n'a pas couvert le champ
militaire dans notre rapport on n'est
pas dans la bonne Commission on aurait
rajouté encore un élément de de
complexité au au sujet deux sur la RDC
c'est le premier pays francophone on ne
peut pas développer la francophonie euh
si on n'a pas des partenariats majeurs
avec la RDC c'est comme faire l'Europe
sans l'Allemagne donc on doit absolument
aller passer des partenariats avec la
RDC sur la la question de l'Est euh du
pays ça fait plus de 30 ans que la
situation est absolument exécrable avec
des des situation on on fait des marches
sur plein de de sujets on doit faire des
marches tous les jours sur ce qui se
passe à l'est de de RDC c'est c'est
indescriptible ce qui se passe là-bas en
terme de de Droit Humain euh la
situation
euh le pésident Français a pris
plusieurs initiatives pour essayer de
d'avancer je pense que la la la la zone
francophone devrait pouvoir agir sont
deux membres de la Francophonie on
devrait pouvoir agir on ne peut pas
laisser cette situation ce déta de la je
suis tout à fait de votre avis c'est un
un enjeu absolument majeur je vais
maintenant donner la parole à Monsieur
Guignot pour une minute oui merci
monsieur le Président pardon madame
monsieur le rapporteur
euh tout d'abord oui je je vous rejoins
sur un certain nombre de vos
recommandations en particulier la
recommandation 31 qui vise à à tenir un
débat tous les 2 ans au Parlement sur
l'évolution de notre politique africaine
il ser en effet je pense sain de reposer
la question africaine dans sa globalité
à la représentation nationale
régulièrement afin d'adapter notre
position face à un continent en
perpétuel mouvement et et en aussi en en
développementm démocratique pardon
toutefois il faudrait peut-être
considérer l'Afrique dans sa dimension
continentale et non uniquement l'Afrique
subsaharienne telle que détailler dans
le rapport mais vous n'avez pu avons
bien compris vous n'avez pas pu tout
faire ma question porte sur votre
recommandation au page 146 dans votre B
le le paragraphe b dénommé la France
autrement en finir avec les irritants
vous émettez la recommandation 73 dans
selon laquelle il faudrait je cite
veiller à un maîtrissage suffisant alors
je vous pouvez peut-être me donner une
précision et puis deè petit point une
seconde qui bloque avez-vous identifié
qui bloque la délivrance des visas euh
important c'est la deuxè partie de ma
question très bien c'est une question
insoluble et donc vous l'avez raison de
la poser brièvement nous allons répondre
rapidement à de voix simplement vous
dire que moi j'ai souhaité que le les
rapports soient soient plus fréquents
devant le l'assemblée de l'ordre de de
deux réunions par an ça me semble
essentiel ne serait-ce que pour
rattraper le le retard de nos relations
avec avec l'Afrique et pour faire le
point je pense que cette commission
aussi devrait se saisir régulièrement de
ces thématique pour qu'on avance en
semble sur le sujet ensuite sur la
question des des irritants c'est mon
collègue Bruno qui va vous
répondre alors pour régler la la la
question de la relation on sait que les
diasporas sont extrêmement nombreuses en
France et communiquent tous les jours
avec les pays avec leur leurs frères et
sœur au en Afrique on ne on a parlé de
double standard on ne pourra pas régler
la question si on ne règle pas nous-même
la question du double standard en France
or une partie des afrodescendants dans
la grande majorité ont l'impression
qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes avantages euh
que que les les les Français vous avez
par exemple dans la rédaction d'un grand
journal d' quotidien dans la service
Afrique sur 14 journalistes vous avez un
seul journaliste qui est d'origine
africaine à RFI vous n'avez qu'un seul
afrodescendant qui a une émission
quotidienne voilà donc il faut régler ça
et je pense qu'il faut plus de métissage
et de mexciter qu' plus de double
standard en France je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur Monsieur Didier
parquan
oui bonjour monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les rapporteurs je
tiens à vous remercier pour votre
rapport sur les relations entre
l'Afrique et la France effectivement je
n'ai rien trouvé dans ce rapport sur les
échanges entre les territoires français
et africains je voudrais vous donner
l'exemple de mon territoire Marseille où
je suis élu le président de la
République veut faire de mon territoire
de Marseille la capitale de
l'Euroméditerranée et nous y travaillons
d'arrache-pied nous avons avec la
Chambre de commerce créé une association
Africa link c'est plus de 250
entreprises qui commercent avec
l'Afrique nous avons créé avec la
métropole po des événements comme
emmerging Valley qui facilit les
relations entre les start-ups africaines
et les start-up marseillaises et
d'ailleurs plus de
start-up africaines euh ouis 350
start-up africaines répondre à des
appels d'offrees nous avons mis aussi en
place un un forum un forum
Europe-Afrique qui facilite les
passerell et nous avons plus de 5000
étudiants qui viennent chaque année
africain étudier dans nos universités
vous l'avez compris nous av avons
compris l'enjeu de de l'Afrique et nous
avons plus besoin de l'Afrique que
l'Afrique a besoin de nous je le répète
nous avons plus besoin de l'Afrique que
l'Afrique a besoin de nous et c'est pour
cela que cela marche alors ma question
est toute simple avez-vous réussi à
identifier des pistes pour amplifier les
relations économiques commercial et
numérique entre la France et l'Que comm
par ça collègue qui répond est-ce que
Nice répond à Marseille avec
plaisir mon collègue monsieur parquan
avec avec plaisir non simplement vous
vous dire qu'il y a effectivement énorme
éormément d'actions qui sont menées
individuellement en France mais il était
impossible pour nous de collecter toutes
les informations et de montrer à quel
point il y a un dynamisme mais un
dynamisme qui est organisé entre par
exemple deux collectivités deux
territoires et et si justement le
ministère de la Coopération donc des
partenariats existai on aurait la
possibilité de de recentraliser alors
pas pour pour bloquer les initiatives
des territoires loin de là mais
simplement pour informer pour pouvoir
relayer et pour P voir aussi profiter de
France méia monde comme ça je je reviens
sur ce qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure qui
pourrait montrer très concrètement les
actions qui sont qui sont montrés et que
l'on peut encore développer voilà vous
savez que sur la question précédente qui
a été évoquée au niveau euh et bien des
de de la présence plus importante des
Africains dans certains dans certaines
structures c'est une démarche qui a été
porté par Bruno fux je ne suis pas sur
sur une démarche de discrimination
positive c'est pas tout à fait ma ma
logique voilà on va pas le soulever ce
ce problème à à l'occasion de cette
réponse euh maintenant c'est euh ellisa
le boucher qui va euh Élise ellise
pardon
excusez-moi merci monsieur le Président
quelques remarques sur la votre
rapport note avec justesse l'absence
d'un ministère pilote unifié la
réduction drastique des effectifs du
ministère et le suivi insuffisant de la
politique d'APD je tiens à rappeler le
manque d'association du Parlement et le
fait que nous attendons toujours la
commission d'évaluation prévue par la
loi de 2021 votre rapport fait écho à
nos critiques sur le recours élevé au
prêt qui éloigne les fonds des pays
moins avancés vous notez à juste titre
le rôle moteur de la politique française
de santé ce dernier pourrait cependant
être largement accru la santé ne
représentant qu'environ 8 % de la
française dernière remarque sur la
suspension de la pour le Mali Burkina
Faso et le Niger ces décision selon nous
une erreur délétaire dont les
populations civiles paient le premier
prix et qui risque d'accroître
l'hostilité d'une partie des sociétés
civiles sans pour autant infléchir sur
les politiques des élites au pouvoir
vous insistez sur la nécessité de mettre
fin en double standard ne pensez-vous
pas que la suspension de la entre en
contradiction avec ses impératifs merci
Madame la député de la SAR formidable
votre brièveté euh je dis juste un mot
je vais être très brève et ensuite
monsieur fux complètera simplement vous
dire concernant les les aides qui ont
été suspendu ce sont les aides au
développement et pas les aides
humanitaires voilà je pense que c'est
très important dans une période où la
France est rejetée d'arrêter les aides
au développement de voir comment les
choses se politiquement mais par contre
les aides humanitaires nous y sommes
tout à fait favor c'est très clair
monsieur fou vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter oui dans en deux mots sur la
commission d'évaluation oui tout à fait
on peut comme vous le le constatez sur
la il faut sur sur sur la FD il faut
quand même voir que une partie très
substantielle majoritaire de notre APD
donc via la FD parce qu'il y a d'autres
façons est sous forme de de de prêt donc
on dit qu'on fait de l'aide au
développement de façon massive en
réalité sur les 15 milliards 13
milliards sont des prêts et donc ce qui
n'est pas du tout l'approche allemande
canadienne ouou ou anglaise même donc on
a dans la réorganisation en tout cas de
de de ce sujet-l globalement on a ce ce
point à traiter je pense qu'il y a trop
de prêt il vaut mieux moins de prêt mais
plus d'investissement d'entre prise et
que le développement soit vraiment lié
au développement avec plus de dons nous
aborderons je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur nous aborderons cette
question plus attentivement quand nous
recevrons madame la secrétaire d'État
par que nous aborderons à ce moment-là
la question du suicide et vous savez
notre profonde
frustration sur les décisions qui ont
été prises à ce moment-là madame Robert
de haut merci monsieur le Président
Madame Monsieur les rapporteur la France
assurer une présence militaire au
Burkina Faso dans le cadre de
l'opération barcane de coup état
successif sur fond de narratif
antiffrançais contraindrant la France à
s'y retirer cela malgré les millions
d'euros investis au Burkina depuis 60
ans notamment pour améliorer la
gouvernance du pays la réaction de la
France est rapide arrêt de la délivrance
de visas au burkinabé classement du pays
en zone rouge et suspension de l'aide
publique au développement ces schémas se
reproduisent au Mali et au Niger qui
figurent dans la liste des pays
prioritaires de l'APD depuis 2013 outre
l'échec de notre politique d'APD nous
pouvons considérer qu'il est
politiquement possible de suspendre
notre APD envers des pays hostiles votre
proposition numéro 81 monsieur
fuch préconise de revoir les critères
d'attribution des pays bénéficiaires de
d' FD ce que nous appelons de nos vœux
depuis longtemps cela va-t-il jusqu'à
considérer qu'il faudrait suspendre
notre aide au développement aux États
qui se montrent peu coopératif avec la
France et qui refusent la réadmission de
leur ressortissant indésirabl sur notre
territoire je vous remercie cette
question très claire et très importante
le lequel des des deux rapport
corapporteurs madame Tabarot
personnellement je je suis totalement
d'accord avec vous je pense que
lorsqu'on a des difficultés avec un pays
on stoppe l'aide au développement et
lorsqu'on a des difficultés aussi pour
faire récupérer nos enfin les dans le
cadre de d'qtf avec les laissés passer
consulaires aussi ça fait partie des
relations qu'on doit avoir avec avec des
pays donc je suis personnellement très
très favorable à à ces à ces vous avez
une une nuance à apporter monsieur une
nuance parce qu' il y a deux il y a deux
sujets en fait il y a un premier sujet
c'est répartition près don en fonction
des des pays et c'est ça la la la
proposition et puis après il y a votre
dont vous avez parlé et puis après il y
a il y a la question des pays hostiles
en tout cas lesquel on a des des
difficultés relationnelles euh là c'est
c'est très compliqué parce que lorsqu'on
a une stratégie qui est la nôtre qui est
euh de parler au aux populations de par
population civile de parler à la
jeunesse et de vouloir déployer des
relations fortes avec tous les acteurs
non militaires et non politiques des des
sociétés euh c'est difficile de voir
quel message on envoie moi je pense pour
ma part que tout ce qui est aide
d'urgence tout ce qui est aide
d'humitaire il faut pas priver les
populations de ce type d'aide là je vous
remercie c'est c'est très clair sur le
la différence entre le court terme
l'urgence et le long terme euh madame
Béatrice Piron député des ielines merci
monsieur le Président je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier Madame Tabarot et
Monsieur fouche pour votre rapport qui
met en exerg la nécessité et les enjeux
de construire une nouvelle politique
africaine pour y arriver vous le dites
vous-même il est crucial que la France
parte de là où elle n'est plus attendu
et recherche de nouveaux partenariats là
où il existe une attente manifeste en
effet aujourd'hui elle est accusée de né
néocolonalisme économique et monétaire
notamment à travers le maintien d'une
monnaie encore appel les Francs dans une
quinzaine de pays africains face à cela
le président de la République a annoncé
en 2019 une réforme de la coopération
monétaire en zone UE MOA
elle a pour but d'opérer un changement
de nom de la devise de supprimer
l'obligation de centralisation des
réserves de change sur le compte
d'opération du Trésor français ou encore
de retirer la France des instances de
gouvernance de la zone franc dans vos
recommandations respectives vous vous
rejoigiez quant à la nécessité
d'accompagner les pays de la zone à
mener à bien cette réforme quand visage
concrètement l'UM mooa comme date
d'échéance et agenda de fin du franc CFA
actuellement ces devises sont encore
produites par la Banque de France
certains pays ne disposent pas
d'imprimerie un nouveau nom et un lieu
de fabrication de ces futurs billets
est-il déjà défini je vous
remercie je vous remercie qui
répond nous sommes en retard hein nous
sommes oui alors aujourd'hui il y a pas
de il y a pas d'échéancier voilà parce
que le sujet a été pris de telle façon
que que les pays africains ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux le Nigéria est pas
d'accord sur le nom de la devise sur le
proc voilà donc il moi c'est ce que je
suggérais c'est que la France avec S
pays africain fixe une échéance pour
qu'on soit pas nous suspecés de pas
vouloir de conserver en fait quelque
chose qu'on a déjà quasiment transféré
donc c'est il faut fixer une échéance
voilà ça c'est pour moi c'est c'est la
clé je pense que si on se permet de
fixer une échéance et de fixer un plan
d'action on risque de nous le reprocher
donc je je pense que c'est au pays de se
mettre d'accord et c'est très bien que
la France rappelle systématiquement
qu'elle encourage les pays à changer
leur monnaie et le nom de leur monnaie
très bien c'est dernière orateur
oratrice d'ailleurs madame
Galzi député de merci monsieur le
Président madamees monieurs les
rapporteurs vous expliquez clairement
dans l'introduction de votre rapport
pourquoi vous avez voulu restreindre
votre champ d'étude à l'Afrique
subsaharienne et en sortir les pays du
Maghreb et c'est intellectuellement tout
à fait satisfaisant cependant cette
restriction nous amène à constater un
angle mort dans les travaux de notre
commission la question des flux
migratoires à travers le Sahara et leurs
conséquences en terme de relations
international et du rôle que la France
peut et doit y jouer elle ne peut agir
de manière cohérente sur les flux entre
pays de la rive nord et de la rive sud
de la Méditerranée que si elle prend en
compte les flux entre pays de la rive
nord et de la rive sud du Sahara de
conakri à Calais en passant par SPAX
pedoua et Menton il y a un continuum qui
nécessite une action globale de la
diplomatie française il serait
souhaitable que le bureau de notre
commission dans sa sagesse se saisisse
de ce sujet qu'en pensez-vous je vous
remercie c'est moi qui vous remercie
madame la députée je pense que Madame
madame tabarou est géographiquement
voilà plus plus proche dei exactement
non non mais je je pense que vous avez
raison enfin c'est très bien que la
Commission se se saisisse de ce sujet si
nous l'avions eu enfin on on aurait été
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure ralenti
dans nos dans nos travaux parce que
c'est effectivement un très gros sujet
qui mobilise aujourd'hui de de nombreux
pays européens dont la dont la France
donc ça mérite que notre commission se
penche sur cette sur cette thématique
là je je je vous remercie alors le la la
séance des des des interventions
particulières est terminé je suis désolé
Hubert euh j'aurais bien vous voulu
donner la parole mais j'avais dit que la
liste était close et on est déjà en
dehors de ça je tiens simplement à dire
en en en échange en en écho à ce qui aux
dernières questions qui viennent d'être
posées que ce rapport est à à vocation à
être une mère de famille nombreuse ou un
père de famille nombreuse je ne sais pas
je me prononce pas et que nous aurons
euh des enfants parce que sur chacun des
sujets qui a été évoqué euh il y a
effectivement des coups d'éclairage qui
ont été donnés et qui doivent être
absolument suivis euh de de de de
réflexion très approfondie je pense
notamment à la monnaie mais pas
seulement je pense effidemement au
phénomène migratoire et et à quantité de
d'affair vous avez éclairé défriché une
partie de la forêt mais la forêt reste
immense encore à à pour être défricher
complètement alors non mais on va on va
peut-être on va peut-être aider Anaïs
faut pas que ça tombe ça tombe sur elle
tout le temps et c'est pas forcément ces
rapporteurs là qui seront chacun mais
chacun ma mes chers collègues aura sa
part apprendre maintenant la le le la
discussion générale est terminée je vais
donc mettre au voix la la publication du
rapport alors j'ai eu une déclaration
très claire je pense que c'était au nom
de renaissance
de du fait que un groupe souhaitait
s'abstenir sur ce sur ce mais on verra
on verra ce qu'il en est euh en tout cas
ce que je tiens à dire c'est que nous ne
nous prononçons pas les uns et les
autres sur le rapport mais sur sa
publication
donc conformément à l'article 145 du
Règlement de l'Assemblée nationale il
revient donc à nous de de voter qui est
pour la
publicationment à voter on
ve qui est contre la
publication qui
s'abstient
bon il me semble
que l'ensemble des des parlementaires
d'abord le le rapport la publication est
autorisée il me semble que l'ensemble
des parlementaires des différents
groupes à l'exception du groupe
Renaissance se sont prononcés en faveur
de cette publication je tiens à le à le
signaler pour que il n'y ait pas
d'équivoque à ce sujet voilà je remercie
nos deux rapport porteur je dois dire
que on nous a annoncé qu'il n'avaient
pas dissimulé leur divergen je constate
aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont pas non plus
dissimulé leur convergenence et et donc
c'est toujours satisfaisant de voir des
rapporteurs qui affichent des positions
convergentes ce qui n'exclut pas
évidemment des différences approches sur
un grand nombre de de de sujets la la
séance est suspendue pour 3 minutes et
ensuite nous passons à la séance avec
Monsieur Gill kpel qui qui a
certainement beaucoup de choses à nous
dire je vous
remercie